good morning members good morning
members of the public you're very
welcome here this morning um apologize
for starting late um but we've had one
or two
complications difficulties and
we had to print some more copies
and what have you um
right but i'll open the meeting and
we'll make a start
first of all i'm going to ask the
officer to read out the health and
safety warnings
thank you chair
um
no there's no planned fire alarm this
morning that we're aware of um my first
reminder of some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite stairs
cold water is available in the breakout
area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room following the
fire exit signs and meet on ipswich town
football club training pitch and please
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
so please ask
members and members of the public to
please switch off their mobile phones or
turn them to silent
thank you
but i would like to remind everyone
present
that this meeting is being broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
accept items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be unfilmed
and to the possibility
use of those images and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film and broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully excluded
so i'm assuming that there is no one
present
that wishes to be exempt
no thank you
no one minds being filmed or
to be absolutely precise okay during
open during times when which we expect
the whole meeting to be to be open no
one has come forward and uh said that
they wish to be excluded so thank you
finally can members and officers please
ensure that the microphone that you
press the microphone for speaking and
turn off when you're finished and can
you also members please lean and get us
close to the microphone because it is
difficult sometimes for members of the
public to hear you at the back
thank you
all right item number one substitutes
and apologies
do i have any apologies yes we do have
one apologies or a chair of councillor
norman
thank you
uh we don't have any substitute yes
yes we do
davis yeah uh councillor davis
substituted for councillor hinton that's
correct yes i had got that noted thank
you
declarations of interest do we have any
councillor parker
yep thank you chair um
item b dc 19 0
4 5 lavender priory
i have business arrangements with the
applicant's agent um they don't affect
the application that's before us so i
intend to stay chat
thank you very much and that's been
noted
any other declarations of interest
no
thank you
um
item three to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the fifth to the twelfth
oh sorry held on the 20th of november
pages five to twelve
i've got copies of them but it's been
brought to my notice that there is a
discrepancy with
page
page seven
uh
79.4
a point of order was called for by
councillor adrian osborne
and so forth um that has been challenged
we are checking the recordings um
this morning and we'll come back at the
end of the meeting and then i'll ask you
again whether
you accept the minutes and i'll go
through them then okay
thank you
so we'll come back to that item
[Applause]
item four to receive any petitions
notification
none received here
thank you
site inspections
is there any
being called
thank you chair
um we have a request for site inspection
for
the blood planning application shown on
the slide there uh land easter church
road in stutten um it's a scheme for 34
dwellings members may recall the scheme
was brought before them on the 17th of
july of this year
but it was deferred for three reasons um
for the applicant to consider further um
there's currently a reconsultation
underway on the revised scheme but in
the meantime councillor mary mclaren has
requested a site visit um and so i'm
just going to run through the details
the application just to remind members
of the scheme and for those who weren't
present at that committee and to show
some photos
so here is the site in stutton and
you'll just see to the
north of the application site and statin
primary school
and here we have church road
starting close
and lower street to the south of the
site
i just run through the constraints of
the site the
site is currently
open green space and is outside of the
existing built-up area boundary within
staton
um also just shown in that plan and as
the circles show the an area of
archaeological interest but also just to
draw attention to ancient house which is
listed building to the south of the site
and just also saturn is a hinton village
within the core strategy
so just the other
constraints the site that shows the
green shows the extent of the area of
outstanding natural beauty so the site
is within it
and it's also within
the
consultation area for
the treble si and so would be there
would be a rams contribution
based on that location to the treble si
so the site itself is 1.75 hectares of
land is designated as countryside as i
said outside of the built-up area
boundary
showing it slightly more zoomed out
there within statin
this is the proposed layout which is
currently being reconsulted on at
present
there's been some design amendments
particularly along the church road
frontage but this would be presented to
members in more detail at the subsequent
committee that this application will be
heard at
but just from my members we've got the
main vehicle access on church road
pedestrian access onto lower street and
pedestrian access onto stutton close
just here where the red dot is
to show this is the revised street
frontage and you can see on this plan
here the red dot shows where we're
looking on the site location plans this
is the street frontage from church road
and
this is the earlier
street scene
which has been now been superseded and
just from my members that this site
there was a current there is an extent
planning consent on the site uh for 34
dwellings which was granted in april
members undertook a site visit in august
2017 which is obviously quite a while
ago now for that previous application
just to run through the photos now um
again you can see the red dot on that
site location plan shows you where the
photo is taken from so here we have the
location of the pedestrian access on
starting close and that's 32 starting
close just to the north so that petition
access is just going to be to that side
of statement close
and then we're in the site now looking
towards the along the back of dwellings
on starting close looking um to the west
across the site and looking to the north
of the site
and then here we're standing to the
north
completely of the application site just
looking towards the development that
borders the uh the applications like
there so they're the two-story dwellings
around that area there
so now moving back around the towards
the south the site here we have that
petition access
and bungalows on sutton close
moving down towards the junction as
shown here with lower streets and saturn
close
and this is ancient house the listed
building pointed out earlier this is the
southie application site
and the pedestrian access
to the south just where the red dot is
there on the photo
and this is looking inside the site to
where the pedestrian access will be sort
of proposed footpath link through to
lower street
now we're on church road so now we've
just gone up to the north west corner of
the site so we're looking down towards
the site access you note the uh
vegetation along the existing
church road there
and that's just looking further south
down church road
and then just one last one looking north
up church road and the site access would
just be
around where the dot is shown now
so that's the uh all the photos we have
on the site um
thank you chair
thank you
members you've seen um the photograph
you've had an explanation
of the site
what do you wish to do do you want to go
along for site inspection or are you
happy to accept the photographs and then
the full presentation in due course when
it comes to the planning committee
which
yes we have the ward member present
and you've requested this for those
reasons
so members what do you wish to do
uh kenza osborne
yeah thank you mr chairman um for us
older members on the committee did we
actually have a site visit previously to
this
yes we we did and that's refreshed my
memories of of the site but because
there are some that may not have been on
site
parker
thank you chair i think it's um uh
eminently sensible that we go along and
uh have a look so i'd like to propose
that we do go inside visit chair thank
you thank you
do i have a second of that cancer i was
born
right
it's been
councillor busby
um
for those older members amongst the
committee that have already been
uh we don't necessarily need to come
again i don't think i think it's
worthwhile new members
going on a site visit but i can't see
that i would gain anything from going
back
i'm quite sure that your presence there
would be greatly appreciated
yeah
yes i i'm
distracted it's oversight site
inspection visit for all members or it's
not so it's been proposed and seconded
all those in favor of the site
inspection please show
that's carried thank you
um so as we don't have a confirmed date
yet chair for um when that would be
going to committee what i would propose
is whatever week it is prior to um the
item coming to committee we will either
sort out the site visit for them if
that's agreeable to members so that it's
fresh in every once yeah if you can get
those dates sorted as soon as yeah once
every day from the case office yeah then
send it out to members so you'll get to
know us as quickly as possible
cancer busby
in that case could we perhaps
combine it with the site visit to
worsted for the petrol station
drive-through restaurant etc etc
as it's just down the road
it is i think we have discussed that um
in briefing but i don't know what
we've done anymore i think it has to
come through the normal yes i think it
needs to come to a planning committee so
we could perhaps bring it to the next
planning committee which would hopefully
be before we go to the site inspection
okay
so uh we'll
keep an eye on that and make sure that
you're informed at the appropriate time
thank you
no
did you what's the comment chairman
before we go into the next due item
which is a
planning application mr carmichael did
draw matters to my attention that meant
we we may need we may need a word
in a break i think if looking at mr
carmichael we we need to speak to
you
so may we take a shorter german please
i think so yes please uh
right uh members i'm not aware of any of
this i'll hand over to the officer and
he'll bring us all up today
well um just to say that the further to
that point there's also a lot of
additional papers that have been put
before members this morning i also need
to check that they are all before me
absolutely
i think there may be one that is not
before members that was received
extremely late that i need to check
further to that we've received another
email that i need to talk to the deputy
monitoring officer mr duprey about
yes indeed
i'm sorry i'm i switched on i know the
morning is is moving on but i wonder if
we need do we need about 20 minutes mr
carmichael do you think 15 minutes 15
minutes
in that 15 minutes adjournment which
i'll make a decision on in a moment
perhaps members you could read those
papers that you have been given this
morning and if there's any others that
uh they're referring to
you'll get them as soon as possible and
i would just like to point out that i'm
getting quite annoyed
at late papers coming in from
applications and objectives now i know
they have a right to object right up
until the last moment but it does cause
this planning committee difficulties and
as you've just found um and heard there
are papers that have arrived at the 11th
hour which we need to see
and make sure that they're given a fair
hearing which i can understand um but
it's not beyond the realms of people to
make sure that they get these in
in a sensible time frame because at the
end of the day
they get the notice and i'm assuming i'm
right here seven day notice the same as
everybody else and other planning
applications do get them
and it does seem that um
you know it's making life very difficult
for us so i hope that people take notice
that mr chairman
uh councillor busby
i mean i totally concur with that uh
chair i think it's ridiculous getting
whatever it is a 40 odd page
uh document this morning well this
morning i suppose it turned up last
night
in our emails but i mean i personally i
think anything that arrives
within 24 hours of the meeting shouldn't
should be disregarded how can we give it
the kind of i mean the original papers
come out a week before which gives us
plenty of time to read them
ask questions chew it over in our minds
give it you know read the papers in on
the um each application things that turn
up this late we might be able to read it
but i mean
how much
way can we give these things it's
ridiculous
uh well i think this is where your
wisdom and expertise and the fact you've
been on planning committees you have to
weigh up but i take your point i i
really do cancer parker yes okay so i
don't want to label the point but just
for clarity then so the last as far as i
can tell the last bit of correspondence
i received was in 1702 yesterday so has
there been a further submission since
then
members
members of the public i think you're all
back does anybody know of anyone that's
not back
that was here earlier
no so chad chairman we did say with the
journal till 10 30 if we're sure we
haven't lost anybody who might be
missing something but we should make
sure that i think what we carry on
i'm told that's one of our officers so
um we're we're all present then i'll
reopen the meeting
and
i'm going to start by
stating that i am here with an open mind
that i have no preconceived ideas
um i would remind members that all late
papers
whether they're from applicants or
objectors
must be taken seriously as i stated
earlier and you must weigh them up and
i'm sure you all will do that
okay
thank you
now
let's see if i'm playing where we are
right
so we've done all those formalities
we'll now move to item six a
and it is chilton waldenfield road and
the case officer is vincent
over to you and your takers thank you
thank you chair good morning members
ladies and gentlemen
first item is a reserved matters
application for 130 dwellings
at the site land north of waldingfield
road sudbury
now the matters before you this morning
for you to consider are landscaping
layout
scale
and appearance
the question of access was determined at
outline stage so access isn't a matter
before you this morning
it is quite a
long presentation um
it is comprehensive in its
spread
what i want to emphasize is that the
site is within the parish of chilton
which is in the ward of
laven we are on the edge of sudbury but
it is in the parish of chilton
the report that you have before you is a
very comprehensive report produced by
stephen stroud and i've highlighted on
the screen the key
elements which result in conclusions on
page 45
and the recommendation on page 46 the
purpose of my presentation is to provide
illustration
to complement and support the text
provided by stephen stroud
in terms of relevant updates i have two
matters to report to you this morning
yesterday i had a long conversation with
the
housing strategy lead
she has confirmed to me that she's
satisfied with
the proposal originally she had some
concern
about the number of one-bed apartments
in terms of affordable
housing but when i explained that they
are provided in three blocks of four
flats
she was more relieved because
she thought originally it was one block
comprising 12 units her initial concern
was
from a letting point of view
the council
potentially allows young children in a
one-bedroom house but not in a
one-bedroom apartment but when i show
you the layout you'll see they are very
generous
in terms of their internal dimensions
they actually comply with ndss
what i would also say is that the
housing strategy lead was very pleased
to note that all the dwellings within
this development will meet or exceed
ndss
standards
i can't recall another site where a
developer has provided 100 of units at
ndss level voluntarily so on that basis
julie abby taylor
is satisfied
but we will continually monitor
applications going forward around this
whole question of one bedroom
units
in terms of drainage you'll notice from
the report that
further comment was expected from our
drainage colleagues at suffolk county
council i can confirm they now have no
objection
on drainage grounds they have sorted out
the technical issues
that were referred to in the report and
they are now satisfied in terms of other
updates
as you can tell from this morning there
has been a lot of doing and throwing of
additional material
and rather me confirm where we are in
terms of the parish council i would
either ask
mr carmichael or
or others to comment on where we now
stand in terms of formal comments
received since the publication
of the report
can
can you answer that question
between
i'm happy to pick that up chair i mean
effectively members will have before
them um a range of uh new comments and
information um and clearly now there's
been a significant period of time for
members to to read that this morning and
take it into account
obviously it goes without saying that
nothing here is less important than
anything that's been received before and
it would be expected of you that you
will take it into account fully and
appropriately and
look at that in in conjunction with
everything else that you've got before
you
obviously there are a lot of comments
here about the nature of the outline
permission and what was set and what is
expected going forward and through these
reserve matters proposals
officers have taken to also read all of
these papers they are satisfied that the
recommendation laid out is still
as is set out and would still commend
that recommendation to you
i think at its heart members clearly
heritage continues to be
an incredibly important matter
but it is wrapped up
not wanting to make this oversimplified
and i would encourage you to consider
the report and its totality
wrapped up in a landscape point and i
think at its knob the question is do you
think the landscape strategy before you
is satisfactory or not but obviously
vincent is about to take you through
a comprehensive presentation which will
cover all of the reserve matters bearing
in mind that this is a reserved matters
application that responds directly to
mass of scale
layout appearance and landscaping and of
course where it is expected to record
with
certain things such as the parameter
plan
um be in general accordance with the
landscape strategy from the outline
stage and also accord with the suffolk
guidance for parking it's officer's
opinion as a matter of planning judgment
that it does all three thank you
back to you vincent
thank you steve
i would want to assure members that
since the production of the report i
have obviously been tracking
correspondence from the parish council
and lady hart and during the
presentation i will be picking up on
points made in those
those exchanges so i will be able to
illustrate some of the concerns
expressed by
chilton and the officer's response
sorry i'll if i may just come in here i
just
think part of the conversation that mr
carmichael and i had in the break was to
clarify certain matters which i think we
were well on the way to clarifying first
thing in the morning and
the um
as the report says the parish council
had not objected initially but they have
they are there is going to be a public
speaker who does who does speak and who
is objecting to the application and i
think it has been clarified now that
we have a letter clarifying the parish
council's position and
it's been drawn to my attention the
letter from michael collins listed
building consultant is said to be on
behalf of both
um a personal objector and the parish
council so i don't know if that
deals with your
mr pierce's
doubt on that point
i think that covers it very clearly and
in preparing the presentation i have
assumed that all comments have been from
the parish until
told otherwise so
so without further ado
i think it's important i just remind
members of the
the nature of the outline
planning permission it was for
residential development for up to
130 dwellings
the reserve matters submission before
you this morning is for 130
dwellings
now an important element of that
permission
i'll draw your attention to conditions 1
and condition 4 attached to the outline
planning permission
condition one refers to a series of
drawings which provide the basis for
assessing the reserved matters and i'll
go through each one of those there are
three key drawings
with you during the presentation
condition four requires
reserve matters in respect of
landscaping
to follow the landscape strategy and
there's a specific specific drawing
there agreed at outline and again i'll
go through that in detail
so already the reserve matters are
constrained by those two conditions so
it's important we do compare what we now
have to what was expected at outline
plan application stage
so that was the site plan
for
the outline planning permission if we
superimpose the reserved matters redline
it fits exactly so there's no question
that what's before you isn't in line
with the outline planning application
the next key drawing is one that stephen
referred to a moment ago
and this is the parameter plan
and that broadly shows
open space and built form and the
relationship and position of those on
the site
it also shows the access
down in that area there
i'll go into a lot more detail as we go
through so
bear that one in mind for for later
the other key drawing the third of the
triple drawings specifically referred to
is the access drawing so that is the
access approved at outline stage
you'll notice
this is the frontage the site sits
behind it and there is the access
if we now look at the reserved matters
layout
so that's waldingfield road running
bottom left to top right if i
superimpose the outline
access over the top
you'll notice it fits
perfectly
so in terms of the access what's being
proposed matches exactly that approved
outline
so i'll move on to the reserve matters
details
slipped one too many
so
red line as previously discussed
to the south west you have some mary's
close chilton prairie to the north east
welding field road running
bottom left top right the b1115
opposite is chilton hall and another
group of buildings we'll go into a lot
more detail of that in a
moment a short burst of video taken
earlier
this month just to show you the interior
of the site so here we're looking back
towards the backs of properties instant
mary's close
so you'll see some archaeological trench
work being undertaken everything in
there up to the boundary hedges is the
site
you can see that some clearance has
already taken place that was at one time
an orchard all those trees have been
removed to prepare the site for
development
so here in this screen in the middle
left we have chilton
hall we have the
garden to children hall and the trees
around it
we will fly
backwards looking back towards chilton
hall
so
that is the registered park and garden
in the foreground to chilton hall
we're about to cross waldingfield road
what you see in front of you now is the
application site
with the
trees that once formed part of the
orchard
we'll then
zoom back out so you can see the
relationship between the site and
chilton hall and other
properties some areas close on the
right
obviously
the
site in the foreground is actually
chilton woods you'll recall the major
allocation and permission for mixed-use
development
so again
we'll just swing around and this is
quite a nice shot because you can see
now the relationship between
the application site on the left
and chilton hall in the top right with
the registered park and garden
sort of biscuit colored fields
in the middle
here we have another aerial shot looking
towards
chilton hall and the
wonderful grounds around it and the
dense planting around chilton hall
that is the application site in the top
left
so i'll just make that disappear and
come back
again another shot looking towards
chilton hall
there's the house itself the
walled garden that is listed in its own
right
the edge of the application site
the access point
from the
edge of the house to walding field road
is some 276 meters at that point that's
just adjacent to the drive
to chilton hall which is also a bioware
and public access
is available along that that route
from the edge of children hall towards
the access of the site
is some 317
meters
we have a large area of
open
land which is part of the registered
park and garden some nearly five and a
half hectares
we have a smaller parcel
within the grounds of jordan hall
and we have several bands of trees
between children hall itself
and the site
you can see the red
rectangle children hall nestling in its
own little area of woodland at that
point
shot across the edge of the registered
park and gardens towards waldingfield
road from the
driveway to chilton hall itself
in terms of
constraints
the most obvious constraint is the fact
that children hall is itself a grade two
listed building
it has a listed world garden as shown on
there
grade two
star
yeah two staff of the house and two for
the walls
in terms of public rights away they're
shown on the screen and we have a byway
that actually is also the access
driveway to chilton hall
so the public can
enjoy
the views towards georgian hall
and beyond
this is taken from historic england's
website just to define the registered
park and garden that's grade two
which encompasses all that land
including the land occupied by
georgetown hall itself
so in terms of heritage assets this is a
very important site it's also expansive
and we'll come on to that in more detail
shortly
putting it in the context of wider
development you'll remember that
recently planning permission was granted
for the chilton woods development that
is the master plan for children woods
and you'll notice the site nestles in
the elbow of
that development all of that land has
been identified within cs4
as a strategic allocation in the core
strategy
so whilst that development has not yet
happened
we are
satisfied that progress continues to be
made towards moving to reserved
matters and the sale of the the site
if approved i suspect that this
development would precede development
within chilton woods
but it would be the first step in the
strategic redevelopment of that whole
area on the
north east edge of sudbury
i'm trying to remember i think the total
number of houses within chilton woods
was originally 105.00
11.50 i'm yeah i'm correct 11.50 so in
terms of housing it is a major
allocation for the district and
strategically it is of vital importance
in terms of our delivery
trajectories
again aerial image of the site putting
it in the wider context of this part of
chilton
layout
so i've highlighted there the
heritage assets
and i've gradually superimposed the
layout that's now part of the reserve
matters now i appreciate that at that
scale it's it's too small to
see the fine grain and we'll go into a
lot more detail but that just puts it in
the local context
so it sits in that sort of it's the
filling between saint mary's close to
the south
west and children prairie to the
northeast
a bit more of a closer view and again
we'll go into a lot more detail we'll
zoom in later
what i want to do now is compare
the outline illustrative layout with
what you have before you in terms of
reserve matters so that
is the outline
master plan that you saw
previously and you'll notice the
extensive
areas of
open space
you'll notice the extensive landscape
buffer
along the road frontage and in the gap
between the site and children prairie
we now superimpose
well we're hoping to
but we can't
something happen there
but what we have
i've done it anyways compare so on the
left we have the outline
on the right we have the reserve matters
and you'll notice that the blue arrow
is the dense area of planting that is
common to both
you'll notice the orange arrow
represents the
swathe of open space that runs across
the middle of the site
that is common to both
you'll notice
planting buffer along the road frontage
that is common to both
you'll notice the broad arrangement of
properties is actually very similar in
both cases
the only difference is a very slight
adjustment of the spine road serving the
site
in that area
there but i will as i say i will go into
a lot more detail
so we are satisfied
that the reserve matters
broadly complies with what you were
expecting at outline stage but i can
provide greater elaboration as we go
through
i think it's important to note
where you were expecting the frontage
properties to be located
so here we have
the outline
layout
which was illustrative and that
black
dotted line represents the
front face of buildings
looking out onto waldingfield road
we'll gradually
overlay the latest layout
what you'll notice is
a number of those properties have
actually been pulled back
from the line you were previously
expecting so the separation between
the frontage properties waldingfield
road and therefore children hall has
been increased
that was a deliberate attempt by the
developers to accommodate
the requirements of the parish council
in creating
greater distance between waldingfield
road children hall and the front of that
built form
you'll notice that the landscape buffer
is common to both
the overall layout we're looking
in terms of the estate road you have a
spine road that
comes from the approved access and then
there are a series of if it was a river
there'd be tributaries becoming smaller
and smaller grain serving the rest of
the
development
the highway authority is perfectly
satisfied with that internal
layout and it does match very closely
what was expected
at outline stage
in terms of character in my view there
are
some key character areas we have a what
i would call village green running
through the middle
we have
rural edge
and we have urban edge so on the urban
edge that's where the boundary will link
up with the wider children woods
development
so here we're looking at the
frontage of the site and what i've done
is highlight the continuous frontage
the built form
and you'll notice that each of those
provides excellent surveillance over the
adjacent open space so if we trigger
that
there are no dark nooks and crannies of
open space that is a carefully
considered layout to provide
good
urban
design
so i'm not talking about the actual
appearance of the buildings simply in
terms of the layout and interaction of
spaces
if we look at the
other half again we've got that
continuous frontage creating a village
green and i'm hoping that the elevations
will
do justice to the village green
i'm trying to describe to you and again
excellent surveillance but what i want
to draw your attention to plot 77 is the
visual focal point of that whole
development and we've required that to
be something rather special and have a
pyramid roof because as we'll see later
it can be viewed from a number of
positions so the pivot
is that yellow building
but in terms of surveillance again
wonderful surveillance over all of that
open space
and for open space to be effective and
well used and for people to feel safe it
has to be well surveilled and that is
excellent in terms of
urban design layout principles
parking meets all your standards as you
would expect
we're gonna that is the yellow building
plot 77 you can see that it it really
needs three
key elevations because it presents three
public sides
to view
so what's shown on the screen is the
main elevation the front entrance
so
excellent design features we've
got sprocketed eaves we've got
flat brick arches we've got door hood
brick banding plinth
exposed for after feet
bay window on the side start introduce a
second
important elevation
originally
it could have looked like that with a
complete blank flank we pushed hard and
secured the
amendments
shown in black and white but that wasn't
good enough in terms of presenting
an interesting public face
to that three-sided building
what we've now got
is that
so in terms of the composition
particularly the one on the right which
overlooks part of the reddish green that
is now an incredibly interesting
elevation and also allows for
surveillance of the adjacent open space
this is something we would advocate that
all developers embrace in terms of
elevations
again you can see now
where you can get views of that open
space from the inside to provide
enhanced
safety and the sense of well-being
using the space adjacent pyramid roof is
does what it says on the tin
here we've got a large overhang which
actually creates a very graceful
roof
but in terms of how it would look there
you have a cgi of that corner turning
building it has a
we've actually annotated some of that
in terms of the detail there is an awful
lot of detail in there which lifts it
far above what you would normally see
on perhaps what we might call more
ordinary
developments
but the quality is not restricted to
plot 77.
every plot
we've worked very closely with anderson
group to develop
i would say
exceptionally detailed elevations a lot
of effort has gone into design quality
materials
and detailing
in terms of the types of units
we have secured bungalows in the area
yellow
immediately to the back of some areas
close
that is the closest part that any
development touches existing development
we have heard and stephen will correct
me if i'm wrong we've had no objections
from residents in saint mary's close
i understand that anderson group have
worked very closely with the residents
to achieve a layout that seems to have
satisfied the residents
the existing residents
there's a
elevation of a bungalow very generous
proportions
two double bedrooms
large
kitchen
diner lounge
another bungalow slightly smaller
remember all of these are up to ndss
standards
so that is the block of one bedroom
apartments
two flats per floor so there's four
flats in each
block and there's an internal
so that double bedroom there's the
bedroom and there is
a significant amount of space around
that bed there's a very large living
dining kitchen
area
we are very pleased to see that the
standards on this development
are the highest we've seen from any
developer so far within the district in
terms of space standards
here we have an elevation across the
village green and how that continuous
frontage creates
an interesting
frontage details extend to brick walls
on all public frontages
every corner turning unit has
an elevated flank wall rather than a
blank
wall
we've even gone down to
details such as finials on the barge
boards the arches
pentis boards
timber porches
this is something that we would
encourage
across the district if we could find
developers who are willing to put this
much effort into design quality
this is a concept but
the developer wants to have street
furniture that has some reflection of
the
past
history of children and here they've
thought about the former connection with
the
usaaf airfield at sudbury
those view that no chilton and sudbury
very well will recall that station 174
towards the end of the second world war
was in fact a base for
us
bombers
so here we have a flying fortress flying
back to sudbury it was essentially the
base for
usaaf liberators
parts of that still remain so
it's a nice touch
for there to be a
reflection back onto the past you can
see how close the airfield was
to
the site itself the site is shown as a
yellow dot and just to the northeast
is the
airfield
again another cgi of the
that's typical of the
quality of the frontages and elevations
again large areas of open space all
looked over by
adjacent properties
boundary treatment as i say we have got
walls brick walls on all public
frontages
but the treatment even goes down to in
back gardens we have the hedgehog
friendly fencing
we have
ecological mitigation throughout the
whole
development
in terms of scale
predominantly
the buildings are two-story
there is a smattering of two and a half
story with the
darker red so you can see
two and a half
in here
two and a half here but
yeah but the majority are two story and
again this is something that the
developer has has worked on in response
to comments from the parish council
originally they were
the intention was to have more two and a
half story units
but that was reduced in order to try and
satisfy the requirements of the parish
again in terms of mix there is a very
broad mix of accommodation
the orange
is the affordable housing and as you can
see at the north western end of the site
that is pepper potted
throughout that development we have a
range of
three bed two bed one bed and four bed
units
we look at the other end of the site we
see the two bed
and three bed bungalows along this part
of the boundary
here we have a larger number of four bed
units overlooking the buffer but again
we have three bed and two bed units so
there is a broad mix of accommodation
cross sections
the cross section at the top here we
have from the edge of the garden
chilton hall
looking across
year one with the
planting buffer
and the tops of the houses here are
below that
buffer line
after
more years
as you might expect when these trees
mature these disappear behind that
that line so if we take a line
here's somebody standing looking across
based on what we know about the trees
that are being planted
ridge lines will be below that sight
line
doesn't that doesn't mean to say that in
the first few years you won't catch
glimpses of the
roofs but what we're saying is
in time that will completely disappear
behind the landscape buffering the
question before you today is
do you accept what the parish council is
saying in terms of they do not feel that
the buffer is adequate and deep enough
to provide that level of
softening and obscuring
or do you go with officers
in our view that it is
adequate and will deliver what you
expected an outline which is a very
dense
natural frontage buffer
i will go into more detail to help
members come to a
conclusion in that
debate that each of you will be having
so i've zoomed in a bit closer because
that was quite hard to
to spot and you can see here so year 15
you can see how these have really
matured but look at the um
trees on the other side of the road i
think anyone who travels up and down
waldingford road will note how it is
characterized by
lush dense planting on both sides that
has grown up over an infinite number of
years we see no reason why that won't
continue in terms of this site
so let's take a look in more detail at
the
landscape
this is a bit of video that i took
last week so inside the site looking
towards waldingfield road so i'm very
close to the
existing boundary hedge looking back
towards chilton hall
but waldingfield road is in the is just
behind that hedge
and as i pan around occasionally you
will catch glimpses of vehicles passing
on the road
so the hedge isn't of uniform thickness
there are some areas that are not as
heavily planted as others but just
standing there i was struck by even at
this time of year
how that
hedge actually creates quite a
a good screen so that you could hardly
even notice the vehicles
let alone chilton hall in the
far distance
but the good thing is that where i'm
standing to take this piece of video
that piece of earth in between will be
part of the landscape buffer
well i'll show you how deep that will be
and what would be planted in it but also
the existing hedgerow will be reinforced
so where at the moment it isn't
as dense as other parts that will all be
brought up to a uniform
thickness so as well as the buffer we've
also got planting replanting in the
hedgerow
this do you remember at the start i
referred to the landscape strategy as
condition four to the outline well here
is that
that strategy
and you'll notice a key part of that is
the planting along the site frontage
and the planting in here and what i
would say is i think you'll notice that
the planting along here is
now thicker than was expected
and i will go into some detail about the
parachutes comments in relation to this
because
that appears
and i don't dispute it that looks to be
quite a dense
planted belt
the thickness of those it almost looks
like broccoli it's so thick in there
and i think the parish council is
concerned that when you see the reserve
matters what's being shown appears to be
a line of trees rather than what we
might call
dense broccoli
i will go into a lot of detail in that
because
i believe the parish council is
misguided
when it comes to
analyzing the planting proposal on that
frontage
so here we have the landscaping scheme
in
not enough detail for you to pick it up
so we'll go into a bit more detail
within this you will see we've got a
mixture of habitats we've got wetland
grassland in this area
we've got wildflower meadows we have
further wildflower
meadows we have the open space amenity
areas
we have play areas play mounds we have
shrub buffers
and there's an extensive list of
planting types
throughout that
so that's the
one half of the site if we
i want to look now into the let's go
back one
okay
now this is the point made by the parish
i can understand why
i have made it
the way that these trees are shown it
would appear that there's a lot of space
around those trees and it isn't the
broccoli that you were expecting at
outline stage but i think what i need to
explain is in order to provide immediate
impact
what anderson group have decided to do
is plant some very large trees
in my 40 years of
planning experience i have never known
so many large semi-mature trees go in on
a site as this
so let's take a look at what i mean
and these are images from the nursery
brochure so these are provided by the
nurserymen rather than me scouring the
web for
typical sorts of trees
so
here we have
an oak
and this is semi-mature so it has a
girth circumference measured a meter
above the ground of 25 meters
so here is in the nurseryman's shot is a
person standing next to that that tree
again hornbeam
20 to 25 centimeter girth that's a
semi-mature tree
there is a person
and we have to remember that person is
actually standing against the root ball
rather than the base of the
trunk but even then you can see how big
these trees are going to be
another shot
field maple again what you would expect
to find in the countryside on the edge
of villages it is a typical
field species
also notice how that planting at the
axis is taken into the site so it's not
just limited to the frontage buffer but
it is almost like a funnel a green
funnel being drawn into the spine road
again to provide
good
buffering of the development behind
so again here we have english oak
semi-mature
if we move that lady so that she's
standing at the bottom of the trunk
rather than the bottom of the root ball
and again this is illustrative because
obviously trees grow at different rates
but for a semi-mature tree you can go
one
two
three
that is a big tree and that's
deliberately designed so that
you get immediate impact so behind the
existing hedgerow there will be
many large trees
already on day one bosch in they go
and again what we're arguing is that in
terms of outlook from let's say chilton
hall and other areas
already above the existing hedgerow you
will see semi-mature
trees so they're already ahead of
whip planting which are the small
tweaks
ultimately
that's what those trees will mature into
so you have the common horn beam on the
left field maple on the right
common beach
we have two
extracts from the nurseryman's
brochure silver birch they'll be planted
at the height that's significant and
again scots pine
not only are they tall but they're also
very wide
so here we have the more detailed
landscaping shot for the piece of the
frontage
now the
licorice all sorts what i've tried to do
here is
identify the type of tree for you which
is the inner color
and the size
so all of those are big trees on day one
so you'll see there's a mixture of
hornbeam oak field maple and silver
birch
but also notice
around them is whip planting so they are
not two four six eight ten trees in
grass they are ten trees within a
heavily planted
belt and this has been designed to
create a whole
canopy of
of different heights
and over time the whips will start to
flourish they grow quite quickly so
before long you get a very dense
planting buffer and it'd be wrong to
suggest that it is 10 trees within grass
ultimately that will be a dense
buffer so you'll have a an immediate
canopy
but over the years
the understory will be growing up to
thicken that whole belt and again we'll
have reinforcement planting on the
hedgerow
so it's a very carefully considered
strategy to provide short-term and
long-term screening
and again on the other side of the
access again
a vast number of
semi-mature trees
in amongst whips and hedgerow
reinforcement
we also have large areas of open space
in line with the outline planning
permission
play areas
in terms of the depth of that buffer
it varies so from the back edge of the
footway
on one end we have 25
at the pinch point we have 14
but generally it's
up to 21 from a general depth of 19.
so to reinforce
what we have is on the inside we have a
planting buffer we are reinforcing well
not we
anderson group would if they got reserve
matters approval reinforced existing
hedgerow but i want to point out at the
moment there's an existing opening
and anderson group are using that as
their
site access
once the development is an advanced
stage that will be physically closed
the whole of that area will be
decompacted
and heavily planted and that access will
be closed so we will have continuous
frontage hedge
entire length of that piece of frontage
now members may recall the outline stage
there was a requirement to have a
pedestrian access coming out at this
point
my understanding is that the anderson
group after discussion with the parish
council
deleted that
footpath connection because the concern
was
anyone going there is no need to go in
that
that direction and it would be much
better to come
inside that hedge and use the footpath
connection which takes you right into
sudbury that's being provided in here
linking with the existing footpaths
so that was another direct response to
local
commentary
excellent future connectivity potential
with chilton woods in terms of
pedestrian cycle connectivity something
i know members were keen to secure what
members didn't want is for there to be
vehicular access through
that is not being provided
but ultimately we will have pedestrians
and cyclists being able to work their
way right through the children woods
development from here
there's the access i was talking about
which is currently the
site access and as i say that will all
be reinforced de-compacted
here's a shot inside the
site showing the depth of the plus
buffer belt and we are looking towards
the back of some areas close and already
harris fencing has been installed here
to ensure that construction vehicles do
not
run over this land so what we're trying
to do is encourage
construction work to avoid decompacting
that piece of land you can always go
back and de-compact artificially
but anderson grouper are trying hard to
avoid having to do that
i suppose they're trying to show
goodwill
that they are intent on delivering an
excellent landscape scheme
another shot looking towards the site
compound
all of that is part of the buffer belt
residential amenity as i said earlier
the closest properties of instant areas
close where we've had no objections the
closest
back-to-back distances are 34 meters
you'll recall these are bungalows
so that is a 34 meter proximity these
are two-story houses and mary's clothes
these will be bungalows
now we have a view looking back towards
saint mary's clothes
chilton prairie to the north east that
is 76 meters away
within this deeper planting
belt here which provides excellent
screening
we're satisfied that chilton prairie the
residential amenity will not be
prejudiced
here we have a shot
of the driveway or the byway which also
accesses shelton hall
i just want to take you on a short
journey down this
driveway
so you'll notice the driveways are tree
tree-lined drive to chilton hall and
along the byway
on the left you have part of the
registered park and garden to
chilton hall
in the distance is waldingfield road and
the
gateway we're advancing towards
waldingfield road again on the left more
of the registered park and garden behind
that hedge
you'll notice there's a property that
comes into
view i think that's called the gatehouse
we have farmland on the right we haven't
got to the entrance point yet to that
driveway
you'll see trees in the distance on the
left around cheltenham prairie there is
a gatehouse
property
we're still going down the driveway
towards waldenville road
so when we get to that entrance point
we'll turn left into waldingfield road
towards
sudbury
so on the right you've got existing
planting gelatin prairie on the left
you've got the frontage
trees and hedgerow to chilton hall
there's the access to chilton prairie on
your right
you remember i said how this stretch of
the road is characterized there's a
slight compound just gone on the right
by heavily treed frontage and there you
have the access to the site that's been
formed
this is a an extract from
parish council
objection
so
what has been drawn to our attention is
the impact of a v from a view from this
point
towards the development
it's like you through a gateway in here
you will see this development
from that vantage point
that may well be true
until the
landscape buffer has matured
i would argue that is a very limited
impact
however
it is something that has been drawn to
our attention so i can quickly measure
that's 301 meters
and that's
sorry let's go back that just jumped 326
meters
you'll notice that the frontage to the
register parking gun was in place is
quite deep but it is fair to say in this
corner
there is a field access so there is a
gap and you can see
out of that gap and you will see
the road
from that point
so what i've tried to do is i've taken a
larger
aerial photograph so you have
chilton hall you have the moat
and here's that big tree from which
seemed to form the focal point for the
view of concern so if we superimpose
that view
over the top
that's where the
it's been drawn to our attention that
there is this
adverse impact on views
in that direction there
as i say
my view is that those distances
and with the additional landscaping
that is not a harmful
impact of such
force to
justify a refusal in terms of adverse
impact on that that view
and or
the setting of the listed building
and
the walled garden
the registered park and garden
in terms of local context we have jordan
hall farm
adjacent to chilton hall
we have sable place
hall gate
and the lodge
and that's the driveway and byway so the
public have access to part of this and
that provides access to chilton hall so
what do we have around chilton hall at
the moment
well there's the farm
jordan hall cottages
those are some of the buildings
associated with the farm
there is hull gate remember on our drive
down
the access way to the entrance that's
the building that sits to the left
there's the lodge that sits opposite the
entrance to the driveway
this is a an extract from the objection
and we would not dispute the fact that
there are parts of the existing hedgerow
that are not as
thick as others and as i say we are
deliberately requiring additional
reinforcement planting
and the landscape buffer will sit behind
that so we are satisfied that
those gaps will not exist going forward
were this reserved matters submission to
be approved
again here we have another shot from
taken from the objection and that piece
of hoarding is part of the site
construction access
and the concern is that the fact that
you can see that
means that there is an impact on the
setting of the registered park and
garden
that is true to the extent
from where this photograph was taken it
looks to me as though that was very
close to the boundary that certainly
isn't taken from
within the within chilton hall in its
immediate environment
but what i would say is you'll recall
that i said this actual area
that access would ultimately be closed
and replanted
so this is a very short-term impact
once the development is largely complete
that will not exist anymore that will
just be part of a green screen a natural
green screen
to me that isn't sufficient grounds to
refuse the reserve matters approval
i've referred to this point about the
broccoli the objection letter says that
i think we're in danger potentially of
misleading the committee who were
expecting that level of planting
by pointing to the group of trees the
mature trees but as i said in amongst
that group of trees there is whip
planting very dense so ultimately it
will
appear like broccoli
so i don't see that there is a
a difference between what was shown at
the outline strategy stage and what
ultimately you will see on the site
that's just to reinforce the point that
within the whip planting there will be
semi-mature planting
i've just put in an extract to paragraph
196 of the nppf because members will be
familiar with the
test
that has to be considered
because
what has been identified here is less
than substantial harm
by
the
established heritage
experts we're not looking at substantial
harm
the test for you is to weigh that harm
to the heritage assets i.e potentially
the setting of the listed building
against public benefits that may arise
from this development and that is
something that you did at outline stage
you've already had that process
of weighing up the public benefits
against the harm
and you concluded that the benefits were
sufficient
to justify the grant of outline planning
permission
but once again you're now looking at the
fine detail you're looking at the
reserve matters so again we're going to
ask you to consider
the impact of those details on the
heritage assets
and carry out that same
balance
our view is that the benefits continue
to outweigh
the harm
the less than substantial harm to the
heritage assets
we need to look at sustainability
because i know that's something that the
committee is
keen for us to pursue
anderson group
is known
as ace
civils company they are beginning to
move into house building they have they
haven't built houses within the district
but they have built houses
in essex and what they're trying to do
is
widen and develop their portfolio
but because they're experts in civil
engineering
when they build out this site they feel
they can save an awful lot of traffic
movement in terms of taking
muck away
through their their efficient use of the
site so they've calculated potentially
1 950
less
lorry movements than an ordinary
developer would do but simply because
they're experts at doing the civil
engineering
we will be looking at the use of
photovoltaics within the development
all the properties will be air leakage
tested
they will be looking to exceed building
rigs where they can
we will have
ev charging to all plots
there is habitat creation ecological
mitigation
footpath connectivity
and water reduction measures all
included within the scheme
as i said at the start all properties
will meet or exceed ndss standards
i believe it's the first development in
the district that that meets that
at the moment voluntary level we're all
hoping that it will become mandatory but
this is a voluntary
commitment
we understand that between june 2019 and
december 19 anderson group had meetings
with the saint mary's close residents
lady hart
chilton parish council
jordan prairie residents
and of course
as the planning authority we've carried
out our own
consultations the development management
service was not privy to the meetings
identified there so members may wish to
quiz anyone who wishes to speak to the
members to see
how did they go what was the nature of
those discussions and on what changes
arose as a result of them
anderson group have entered into a
statement of common ground with us
you'll recall that delivery is important
to the
district in terms of ensuring that we
are delivering at the rate the
government wants us to deliver
anderson group have predicted that are
they
were they to be successful today
by 2023 they would have finished the
development
so in
2021 20 units will be completed 21 to 22
75 and 22 to 23 35
that is good for our figures it's good
for
the district
and it is good for a springboard for the
wider children woods development
so having run through that in
quite some detail officers are satisfied
that the reserved matters
do justify
an approval
with conditions
and they are actually all the conditions
are set out in the tabled paper so
rather than just give you headlines we
have given you exact wording
thank you
thank you vincent for that very full and
comprehensive report it was very very
useful very detailed
right we now come to public speaking
and
i just want to say that
on
monday when the vice chairman and i had
our briefing
we were given advice from monitoring
officers
and the
solicitor
and that advice we do we do take and so
we follow procedure
that procedure
was
forwarded to all those concerned
this morning it changed because we had
the parish council had responded
we were then at five years the vice
chairman and i by the management officer
and the legal people that we
should allow the
objector to have the parish council to
have their spot which we eagerly agreed
to because we felt that they should um
so
all these procedures are what we
normally have and we have followed them
to the letter
both the vice chairman and i were happy
with that
pencil plumb you concur
thank you very much
um
right the parish council
is represented by lady hart lady hart
you have three minutes in which to
address the committee perhaps you'd like
to come forward you can sit or stand
perhaps you'd remain seated or standing
at the end of that and i'll see if
there's any questions for you
thank you
good morning
the best planning outcomes are those
where competing interests are resolved
um
the applicants
at the outset the applicant said agreed
with me that they would consult the
parish council on their scheme before it
was finalized and before they submitted
it but they didn't do that they went
ahead
and we were asked and we
were presented with submitted plans
there have been a lot of discussions and
meetings with the applicants
we've tried to sort out a number of
things and there are few issues
outstanding which i would have hoped we
could have resolved the principle of
development of 130 houses and the access
isn't in dispute but there's been no
opportunity at outline stage to discuss
anything else it was all reserved and
this was supposed to be the opportunity
that the public and other people
affected could raise it
what's an issue here is a question of
harm to heritage assets and the harms
avoidable here
by the taking of certain steps please
would you read mr collins letter and
ruth l wood who's a landscape architect
summary of about the trees
the arc the mr pierce has taken you
through the applicant's revision but the
revision about the buffer is is four
meters increase and ten more trees so
it's not a huge increase it's not
significant and it's not acceptable to
the parish council and that's not just
the parish council it's heritage um
england who are a mandatory consultant
and the government trusts
and other council teams who tell you
that the scheme isn't good enough and it
needs improvement it's a legal
requirement that those consultees are
consulted and normally
local authorities follow their advice
you've had very firm advice here you've
been told that to refuse permission and
for your officers to seek
improvements and we are puzzled why your
officers aren't following that advice at
all
none of your officers nor the applicants
heritage advisors have been to the to
chilton hall to look at the site in
actuality although obviously somebody
had been in the car
um unknown
but but here the officers are preserving
their our preferring their views when
they haven't been there to the experts
who have been there
um and you haven't had the benefit of
the site visit either to make you know
to understand it
it's agreed here that harm will be
caused that's not in dispute i heard mr
pearce saying he doesn't think harm
would be caused but that is not the
agreed view
any harm to the significance of heritage
assets needs clear and convincing
justification so what's the
justification here for not making the
improvements
it's expected thank you
lady heart your time is up
if you remain said i'll see if there's
any questions for you
members do you have any questions on
what you've just heard
counselor davis
it's more of a clarification um
forgive me if i'm wrong but i believe we
have visited this site not not this
present committee but the previous
committee so when we we we looked at it
um and when the outline permission was
granted
as part of the day we looked at um the
other part of children woods i mean i'll
happily be corrected if i'm wrong but i
i remember seeing this site and i don't
wouldn't go over that area ordinarily
um
can you help on this
[Music]
i'm aware that we have seen it but i
think the question was put and in
fairness to the parish council they need
a response so can you
to to what question the officers had
visited the site so officers have
visited the application site yes and
it's as is typically the case in any pla
planning application officers exercise
judgment they're used to assessing
impacts and likely effects based on the
relationship between sites
and we did see the video taken all beard
in a motor car i think
um
any other questions
can i think in fact because it wasn't
the question was addressed
to the parish council as you said i mean
if you i think we should ask the
representative of the parish council
what precisely why
the absence of a site visit at this
stage is considered
a problem is that yeah
being a site sorry as far
as if you're happy to answer by all
means dude yeah
um as far as i'm aware there's been no
sight visit on the on this application
if if if you've gone there
um on the state the thing is though if
you've gone down the footpath
um you will you're not in the middle of
the
rpg sort of core so you can't see
because you're on the other side of the
property
um councillor mayberry will know that so
you're not in the park that you can
actually see you're not in the walled
garden you're not on the motored
platform and there isn't a byway by the
way
but thank you i think you've answered
that question any other uh cancer parker
um thank you chair um lady heart
obviously we've just received a very
very comprehensive report from our
officer
but it's it's your contention
or if i can ask the question is it your
contention then that the
the information contained there
specifically around the buffer and the
tree planting
did you consider that that's
fundamentally flawed than what we just
heard
you could and it's not just my opinion
it's english heritage opinion it's the
garden trust so the statutory consultees
are advising you to refuse permission
and to seek improvements
because they don't consider that the
buffer is is sufficient
the applicants say it's an impermeable
screen i wish it was it isn't it's 48
trees and ruth elwood who's a landscape
architect she's done um quite a
comprehensive report and i've asked you
to please read that
thank you i think that's a good
comprehensive answer any other questions
no
thank you
right i'm now going to ask
the objector which is lady hart um to
have three minutes and the same
procedure close thank you when you're
ready
effect officers to seek here the public
benefits arising from the development of
130 houses but in a way which avoided
harm to the heritage assets so all there
needs to be is an increased buffer more
trees it corresponds with condition for
in the drawing that you see it saw
broccoli as mr pierce described it but
broccoli is stated in that
plan to be
grid planting at 2.5 metres and it's a
way of planting you get trees in much
more densely and they grow up to be a
screen which regardless mr pierce's
expert opinion on that do not grow they
will take years
ruth elwood's opinion is that it will be
visible in perpetuity because the trees
won't grow and the cross sections that
you were shown are illustrative all
those trees and shown there are way
bigger than the actual trees are being
put in on the drawings
so if i run out of time please read
elwood's report
you need to decide here if the scheme
before you is the best scheme that can
be approved within the outline planning
permission lots of consultees tell you
it isn't we believe it can be improved
it's not difficult to improve it so
please bear that in mind
we think the key plots one 130 to 125
need to be reduced because they're going
to be visible over any tree barrier
and the land at children hall contrary
to the long section mr pierce took you
through that's inaccurate ruth elwood
points out to you how that is inaccurate
the land falls the other way
um so
we need single story
housing
there's very few bungalows here six
bungalows on that full site so they
could put five more running across the
frontage we're not asking for other
changes and we're asking for a minimum
of 20 meters
buffer width and increase planting on
the grid planting system and then it
will be dense
and we don't understand why the
applicants are so resistant to it
the buffer needs to run along the full
length of the site frontage
on their drawings they don't show that
trees need to be planted in more
quantities significantly more in order
to get staggered grid
the open space is there not by a design
but because there's a restrictive
covenant in favor of chilton priory for
50 yards so that's why that is there
just so that there isn't any confusion
about that but we think these
improvements are easily made we've had
long discussions about them but we've
got to the stage that those are the
points that we can't agree
i'm happy to answer questions
thank you haven't used all your times
uh right
members uh councillor barrett
thank you um i just wanted to clarify
because i think we heard from the
officer can you get closer to your mic
sure i think um we heard from the
officer that discussions had taken place
between you and the developer
but you're
suggesting that those discussions
haven't taken place
what happened was originally it was
agreed that we would see the parish
council
we were consulted quite late
and not and just before the plans were
about to be finished i was told they
weren't finished so we couldn't be shown
them and then it was agreed between
myself on behalf of the parish council
mr children's and the press officer
of anderson that we would be shown the
plans before they were finally finished
that didn't happen they were just
submitted and we weren't told
so we were in a position then that you
know progress is starting and we're on
the back foot when we then so then we do
we do have discussions they continue
i hosted meetings at my house with their
landscape advisors our landscape
advisors to try and
sort out what we could and
indeed quite constructively we agreed
certain improvements like type trees and
things like that
the sticking point we reached is the
width of the buffer
and the
the number of trees to be planted in it
and this grid matrix system and it's the
grid matrix system that results in
broccoli
but it it's achievable
and if you look closely at that
condition for plan it's in the key so it
was approved that the density was
supposed to be this 2.5 it's in the
green strip it's really difficult to
read so you need to blow it up
and all we're asking for is four meters
density i think you've answered that
thank you i think councillor barrett you
should put the same question to the up
to the uh applicant um
because there's some good points come
out there um any other questions
uh councillor
yes
um yeah thank you again lady hart
you will understand perhaps more than
most that as a decision-making body
we can
only make decisions based on what's
before us
so
just so we can have absolute
clarification
on your point of view as an objector
uh there are circumstances in your
opinion
uh under which you would support
this application
speaking as an objector and for the
parish council because it's a common
view
we we would suggest to you that you
recommend you ex you recommend
permission but you do it subject to
conditions that provide for a buffer of
the minimum width of 20 meters
and you require the planting
i could run through the points if you'd
allow me to
but i can give them to mr duprey for you
know drafting purposes but it could be
easily done and if
it benefits the residents of the scheme
too because it will protect them from
noise that will give a wider ecological
corridor so i think it's a win-win for
both sides thank you
any other questions um councilman
jemison
uh morning lady heart
can the uh
the applicant giving you any reasons why
they're reluctant to
concede to your request i think
practically what's happened they've got
down the track for a certain extent
and so um and uh what has happened is
that their architects drew the site
outline first and then their landscape
architects were asked to fill in the
bits now had they approached it had and
that maybe the architects didn't read
all the conditional approval drawings
with it but
had they done it the other way around
they could have put in a buffer and then
done the site layout they approached it
from the wrong way around we say and we
know they did it that way
thank you i think also cancer jameson
i'd suggest you put that question also
to the applicant
any other um comments councillor busby
uh good morning lady hi um
whether i agree or disagree with your
points of view that just the
question as to
could you describe the harm that you
feel will come from
seeing a roof of a building through a
tree from 300 meters it's not going to
be just retreat
and it's not a view it's a heritage
immunity because there's been a lot of
discussion about views so it's not
residential immunity we're talking about
here
i'm in the fortunate unfortunate
position of being custodian of these
heritage assets so i really feel it's my
duty to look after them it's not just
the house is elevated
so the sections are wrong so treat them
very carefully they've been admitted to
be illustrated to us
so you're looking down so you can see
from the house it's really unfortunate
that the access is right opposite the
the gateway into the
historic park and garden and
i tried to get it moved on the in on
outline but nobody paid any attention to
that i don't know why it was chosen to
go there because if it was further east
it would
cause less harm thank you
uh any other questions
members
no
sure thank you very much thank you very
much lady hart
we have no support at present
we have the applicant agent jen carroll
and timothy chivers
you have three minutes between you it's
entirely up to you how you
decide to do that
but at the end of the three minutes i
will
see whether there's any questions for
you
when you're ready
good morning chair councillors and
members of the public my name is
jennifer carroll and i'm the planning
agent from strutton parker
representing anderson design and build
anderson are an award-winning house
builder and groundworker specialist
delivering and building homes and
supporting infrastructure across east
anglia from their base in chelmsford
this site represents their first in the
district of baber and is a landmark
project for business growth
a main focus on all their sites is
legacy
ensuring schemes are of notable quality
encompassing three key principles
these are excellent and attractive built
form
place making and landscaping
as members are all aware outline
planning permission for the site was
granted for up to 130 new homes
including access on the 5th of july
in addition to the access a development
parameter plan establishing clear
locations on the site suitable for
critical landscaping as well as built
form was also approved
the applicant subsequently amended the
development parameter plan to increase
the amount of strategic landscaping
along welding field road and to provide
additional screening and distance of the
built form from the heritage asset to
the south
this buffer now stretches over 19 meters
along the boundary of the site
the application before you seeks
approval for reserve matters only and
the matters therefore relate to
appearance landscape layout and scale
anderson are acutely aware of the site's
heritage sensitivities which has
informed the proactive engagement with
all parties from the first day of their
ownership
the proposals before you are a
culmination of many months of technical
work by the applicant
engagement with your offices statutory
consultees and local residents
this process of community engagement is
how anderson works and has positively
informed the scheme before members today
the scheme has been carefully designed
to ensure there are minimal impacts on
the existing residential properties of
some areas close
through the inclusion of bungalows and
separate boundary fencing and to ensure
that intervisibility with the registered
park and garden to the south is
minimized through substantial and
permeable landscape buffer along with
carefully designed buildings
the development will provide a mix of
new homes suitable for a range of
demographic
and the layout includes generous areas
of open space with public art paying
homage to the historic air base due east
the homes have been designed to meet and
exceed the nationally described space
standards and incorporate the delivery
of 45 affordable homes
five of which will be available for
local parish housing following
consultation with members
in addition to contributing towards
meeting the help meeting need meeting
needs of the housing crisis the scheme
will also provide pedestrian cycle links
with the wider chilton woods master plan
area
and notwithstanding the great importance
of this strategic landscape buffer it's
also important to highlight that
development will contribute
towards education local junction
improvements and the provision of the
on-site affordable homes
as a result of our engagement before and
during the application we are pleased to
receive the favorable recommendation by
officers
our engagement with officers and thank
you very much i'm afraid your time's up
um if there's any questions
members do you have any questions to our
last speakers
counselor barrett
as has been suggested i better ask you
the same question although although i
think
when i asked lady hart it was because
she had suggested
something different to the officers
had advised um but again um can you tell
us about discussions you've had
uh leading up to this application with
members of the parish council and lady
hart and and others
um sorry can you hear me um
yes so we we we as soon as we purchased
the site the first thing we did was
write to our immediate residents in the
parish council
because because that's what we do we
really do try and have a bottom-up
approach to uh how we we design the
schemes
and um so we met with lady hart in her
capacity as chair and also as a
neighbour as well
unfortunately we had to get the the
planning application in because we own
the site and because
you know it's a very costly scheme i
think you've seen and the officers have
presented well the quality we are
looking to put into this development
and so it's really a balance about you
know making progress as a business
but also making sure that what we're
doing is is really reaching the quality
required and so
we put it in absolutely in the knowledge
that we would have to revise things
we have undertaken further discussions
including a presentation to the parish
council at their formal meeting
and successive meetings
including a meeting with our advisors
james blake associates on site
with with the parish council's retained
advisors and
as lady hart says they were constructive
discussions um you know the planting
specification was amended uh further to
request
and there were several key changes
that arose from those discussion as well
quite fundamental changes actually
so just in terms of three main ones i
think it's worth pointing out
we moved the entire parcel of southern
built form uh further northwards by five
meters and i should just say that the
submitted plan was based and informed by
the outline absolutely so it was
entirely in accordance with the plans uh
officers presented with you but we went
further than that uh following the
discussions so we moved the parcel of
built form some five meters further
northwards i think perhaps you have
answered that question that you have had
the discussions you may be able to bring
those points in if other questions are
asked thank you any other questions
members
uh councillor jefferson
morning um
it seems the breakdown seems to be on
the
buffer zone i'm just wondering if you
could explain what
why that is happening what he's stopping
you conceding to the requirements for
better planting and
widening the buffer zone
yes we have widened it very
significantly
from what we had put forward originally
which was in conformity with the uh the
approved outline requirement so we have
gone further
and and james blake have updated the
specification um and they've gone
forward with very detailed uh proposals
which in their experience and they are
very experienced local practice
what they have put forward and what we
have put forward
is incredibly robust and it will allow
for a very comprehensive landscape
buffer to form uh there and that's in
terms of the heights of it and the under
foliage as well to really create that
dense
growth and
in terms of how far we can go we really
have gone as far
as we believe is necessary taking the
advice of our experts who will provide a
watching brief over the implementation
as well i hasten to add
but it really is a balancing exercise
you know there are other considerations
at play here
for example highways drainage
you know urban design so it's really
just about balancing what can be
competing interests and coming forward
with a comprehensive scheme
members any other questions councillor
parker
yeah um i just wonder if um you could
give us some sort of sense uh
when you took this application site on
um
how much weight or importance did you
give to the heritage aspect
of children hall
you can just give the committee some
sense of of how you prioritize that
place
yes of course we we knew it was very
important um both from the history and
the and the the planning file of the
outline uh the fact that obviously the
decision of this council was subject to
litigation as well so clearly from our
perspective we knew that that was a very
very key consideration
and you know an absolutely fundamental
thing that we have born in mind and all
of our instructions from day one to our
team of landscape advisors has been make
sure that that is a robust landscape
buffer and i should also add that
through pre-application engagement with
your officers it was made very clear to
us that that is a very key consideration
amongst others which include you know
retaining the the public benefits uh
that flow from a scheme of 130 new homes
any other cancer busby could you flash
up slide 76
please
and whilst we're waiting for that to
come up um
the issue of uh the visibility it's kind
of kind of a choice between i guess
increasing the buffer or reducing the
height of the houses one of the other
issues or a couple of issues that came
out was
the
high number of
four-bedroom houses on the
on the site
and the lack of bungalows could you not
resolve those two issues
by
has been suggested change the the four
four bedroom houses on the front of the
site to perhaps
four bungalows or two uh semi-detached
bungalows lowering the height and
therefore
uh making the view less likely
that would seem an easier way after
doing it rather than trying to move
everything back five meters as you can
see
although we talk about
15 meters you've got nine meters there
is that not a possibility that you could
alter those first four
houses
i think what i would say in answer to
that is is
the parameter plan which was approved at
outline uh set a maximum ridge height of
9.5 meters
what we did following engagement with
the the parish council and their
advisors was actually to go back
to our house type range and reduce the
ridge height we were proposing in that
entire southern
parcel to nine meters
so we did we did actually take heed of
that and try and respond positively
in doing that
doing that change um that that stems
from the benefits of a a bespoke housing
suite
as is before you thank you
any other questions members
jefferson
uh one of the
conditions is um planting after care has
wondered what is going to be put in
place to maintain
planting in that area and that buffer
zone
well as as part of the section 106
obligation in addition to to the to the
proposed condition um anderson need to
supply open space specifications
including the long-term maintenance
strategy and how that's funded
but in terms of what we're going to
submit in order to discharge that
condition fully is and we have sort of
indicated the level of detail we'll be
supplying is a watching brief
an implementation strategy a
decompactation aeration of soil to
ensure that the longevity of the stems
and the girths of the of the mature
trees that we're planting
will be maintained in perpetuity in
addition to that we've required a
10-year
aftercare maintenance minimum
um so
which is in addition to i think it's
five years is the normal
we think we've
we're robust in our strategy effectively
and we're comfortable and confident that
we've got the information to submit
thank you is that that does that answer
your question sufficiently yeah thank
you
uh you're itching to come in there if
it's very brief
it is chair thank you um just as a as an
add-on to that i would say that the
planting we are coming in with and the
officers alluded to this is a very
substantial undertaking cost undertaking
and it is certainly not in our interest
to
plant it not in accordance with best
practice and not ensure that the
irrigation
and the aftercare is there to ensure
that it gets established
and grows into what will benefit not
only sort of the heritage angle but
equally our future residents um in terms
of their amenities
any other questions members
counselor osborne
thank you mr chairman
i'm a little bit
um
where it's questionable i'm not
i'd like clarification about this buffer
zone obviously
the chilton chilton parish council have
gone through this they're still asking
for extra
buffer zones within that area and i
noticed from 101 of the report
from 14 meters envisaged originally it's
gone now to a depth of 21
at the widest and 19 more generally
we're looking at i think it was uh
number 76
uh
you have still
you're still not actually providing that
24 21 meters buffer or 19 meters is it
more generally it's widest so why
why can't you actually
get that arrangement all the way through
you know i just want clarification of it
because i'm getting i'm getting one uh
uh questionable uh thing from the
council and one from you
it reduces in size as well yeah i
understand the way the road works but
that's your question too yeah can you
possibly answer that
um yes yes happy too uh so it creates
we're trying to create a slightly
sinuous uh edge to the northern bit
the depth we are assured by james blake
as i say who are very experienced in
this they may have a different
professional opinion to other parties
interrogating their work
but they are absolutely
categorical that the depth of planting
is adequate obviously the measurements
there you've got to take account of the
the existing hedge row uh albeit there
are is gapped in places that will be
reinforced as well right up to the
boundary so it will be a very
substantial um
i'm going to
the officer can perhaps clarify this
point uh councillor osborne so i'm going
to take his clarification now
thank you chair just really as a point
of information on slide
what i've done on that slide
is
thank you
so what we have here is a series of
measurements so here i've gone from the
back edge of the footway
to the inner edge of the buffer and that
is 23.
next one down i've excluded the
gap between the existing hedgerow and
the back edge of the footwear so the
total depth including the existing
hedgerow and the buffer is 20.
this one is inside the existing hedge
the depth of the buffer is 14 but
clearly
the actual depth of planting will be
closer to the 20 if i were to have
included the existing hedgerow so when
we get down to nine meters
that is the pinch point in the buffer
but there is also the additional width
of planting that is the existing
hedgerow and as you can see just a
little bit to the south the overall
depth is 14 meters so in the report
we've said
it it can reach up to 21 which it can
generally it's around 19 but there will
be pinch points we recognize there will
be pinch points
what i'd say here is where this
the actual
narrowest element is
actually opposite you have garages
okay you have a house here and a house
here
but immediately at that pinch point set
back into the distance even further
is a single story garage
i just wanted to confirm why there are a
series of measurements on there they are
each measuring a different
element
thank you hopefully um that clears up
some of your
council osborne any other questions
members
no
thank you very much for that thank you
that should return to your seats
all right we have no county councillor
present
the
ward members councillor arfi and
councillor may be a present i know
councillor mavery wishes to speak i've
got down that councillor arthur doesn't
but if you if you want to just put your
hand up you're here i wouldn't refuse
you uh councillor mabry you are down to
comment you'll have five minutes in
which to address the committee
if at the end of that and there's
questions perhaps you'll stay there and
answer them thank you
when you're ready
thank you mr chairman
we have heard today how the outline
planning permission for this site
known locally as the orchards chilton
was achieved last year
today the planning committee is being
asked to decide on the reserved matters
of this development from which is being
presented before them
chilton parish council do not object to
the development of housing on this site
but they do have concerns which they
have voiced and illustrated through
partner specialists
i too have supported statements
regarding heritage buildings
i have in the past and i will always do
so
it is pertinent to remind the committee
that chilton hall although only part of
the original memorial building
from the 16th century
is unique in being the only manual
building left within the immediate area
as the manners of great welding field
little waldenfield
and acton have been lost over the
centuries
we need to defend this tudor survivor
to preserve it for future generations in
a situation that is suitable for its
minority status
there is a question
of public compared to private view here
a private view from a property is not a
material consideration for planning
however a public view is
and i would argue that a listed property
such as chilton hall has a public view
from its vistas
as by its nature of being a property
worth listening listing
to preserve and conserve it
is of public interest and therefore any
view from its cartilage is a public view
as the district councillor for the
parish over the last four plus years
i have investigated the history of the
parish and understand how the village
waxed and waned over the decades
i have listened to all sides of the
deliberations of this development the
latest chapter within the parish history
i commend the due diligence of children
parish council
i support the call for the heavy
landscaping to the front of the
development to the b treble 1 5
and the suggestion that perhaps the
front this front
housing
could or should be also a maximum of one
to one and a half story
however i also commend the development
developers
for their engagement with the community
their care to the cul-de-sac east at
saint mary's
their attention to detail on the
proposed housing
their nod to the history of the adjacent
second world war airfield
their respect for the area
and for the residents they have met as
well as their interpretation of the
undulating landscape because it does dip
managing distinctive topography
the addition of housing for local need
as well as the level of affordable
housing is and will be of great benefit
to the area
these are in my opinion
the type
of developer we would wish to attract to
our district
i ask that the planning committee be
minded to approve this development
with conditions
a
the frontal landscaping to the b treble
1 5 is enhanced
to preserve the feeling of rural
isolation of chilton hall
i feel this could be achieved
perhaps even at a later date
with the addition of smaller trees
interspersed
with the larger planned specimens
and also
b
housing at the entrance be reduced
further in height
perhaps even to a one and a half story
which would preserve the public view
from chilton hall
thank you
thank you very much council of avery
members is there any questions you've
got
that you wish to put to counsellor
no
thank thank you very much
uh councillor alfie you are present do
you wish to speak uh just give us a
minute for this to run through
that's it all right
yep we'll put you on time you have up to
five minutes okay
and you can stay there and uh if there's
any questions perhaps should answer them
thank you okay thanks um i won't speak
for very long at all actually um
first of all i'd just like to
thank vincent pierce for his
presentation um as you know i well i
chaired committee for quite a long time
and i've sat in um committee meetings
for for a long while as well and i have
to say it was one of the fullest um and
and one of one of the the best
um presentations that i've heard
um also um i'd like to thank councillor
mabry for what she's said
she's expressed the views of
the the parish council i think and
certainly
addressed the objections
from
valerie hart at chilton hall
all i'm asking
is that you satisfy yourself regarding
the proposed buffer i think you've
probably picked up this morning that
this is um the the single most important
part
you satisfy yourself that it is
sufficient that it has the right mix
and that it affords screening during all
seasons
with
multiple canopy layers
so that's what i want you to concentrate
on thank you
thank you very much for that good advice
members have you got any questions you
wish to put to counselor arthi
no
thank you very much pennsylvani thank
you very much councillor mabry
there anything you wish to say that no
no
members we're now in open debate so who
would like to start
counsellor busby followed by councillor
plum
thank you
well to me it seems like an excellent uh
development to propose development it
just seems a shame that we've got to
this
final part and there's this just a
little bit of
disagreement between what is and what
isn't a satisfactory buffer
having spent so much time on
focusing on the detail
and the quality of the
development
it just seems a shame that we've got to
this bit and i'm not certain
what the answer is personally i would
like to see the houses reduced to
bungalows or shelley bunk loads so that
you cut the height of the the housing
down
that seems to be an easier solution than
trying to redesign the whole site by
pushing the boundary back by five meters
i mean maybe there's a condition we can
put in where there's a test in five
years that if
if the view is
um
is still
visible if the
buffer has not worked then further
planting has to take place
i don't know how we get around the
this impasse between
what will be a buffer
and what isn't a buffer it's
perhaps we could let the officer think
about that for a moment and i'll get an
answer for you on that but in the
meantime while you're thinking about
that i'll uh take cancer plum
got it at last technology and me don't
go together thank you chair um i've got
a simple question we keep talking about
the number of bungalows on the
development um
i know the chair is very keen to have
more bungalows in the district um i'm
played with a ward that's got a glut of
them
okay
can can somebody tell me what sort of
proportion of the houses we should be
aiming at bungalows before we move on to
deciding whether this mix is the right
mix
that's two questions i think for you to
answer perhaps you can take that one on
board as well
currently we do not have a policy that
specifies a ratio for bungalows in our
local plan or course strategy it is
something that's been considered within
the joint local plan but at the moment
there isn't a requirement
yes i can assure you that um the local
uh japan committee which are looking at
this at this moment in kenzler uh alfie
is a co-chairman of it um this does come
up about bungalow so i'm sure he'll take
note of that for you
and the answer to the question the
principal busby as to whether
if
we were minded to approve it and the
buffer
wasn't as secure as
they make it out to be
could we add
extras then i think basically what
you're saying
i'll look to um stephen but in my mind
i'm thinking
we have a landscape management plan but
what if that was
tweaked
to allow a review
towards the end of the construction
period 2023 where we can
assess
how well the landscaping is doing
it's almost an open
check so i'm a little bit nervous but
there may be a way i i i defer to
stephen and his
it's coming over to you
well actually just to rewind slightly on
the mix point i think it's important not
to look at housing mix for mix sake
because it's not a reserved matter
before us
it's not for us to say that there aren't
enough bungalows in terms of the
open market housing certainly affordable
housing is important because it does
form part of the 106 agreement but we've
heard that the strategic housing lead is
satisfied so in terms of the bungalows
it's really more about the scale of the
development
and in that respect of course you know
the outline permission and the balance
that was struck
in terms of harm versus benefits was
carried out last year when
permission was granted and there is a
parameter plan it is important it does
set that there is a maximum height uh no
more for dwellings to uh provide for
meat um they they fall under that um
there is an argument of course that if
at the time members felt that that
uh
element of the parameter plan was a
particular concern they could have
lowered that
um
threshold but we didn't we assessed it
on the basis of there being a maximum
height of nine and a half meters
nevertheless that does not get away from
the fact that we need to be absolutely
sure that the reserve matters before us
is consistent with the outline
permission that's been granted
and the need of course to minimise harm
or eradicate it entirely which of course
would be preferential and you you've got
before you in the report officers
assessments i think it's certainly
rational reasons are given why um
officers are giving the recommendation
that they are in terms of the
presentation of the landscape buffer and
what this ultimately comes down to is
whether members feel that that strategy
is appropriate or not and as it sits it
does accord with the parameters plan the
thickness there that's dedic you know
defined by that
and the spacing and distribution of the
built form of development
as relating
in terms of
a kind of review mechanism within a
condition
i'm not quite sure how how that would
work in practice
if members want to continue to push on
that door it's something we can perhaps
reflect on and maybe pause slightly so
we can speak amongst ourselves but what
i'd say in the first instance is
you have a strategy before you that's
been provided by the applicants
they feel and which is endorsed by
officers and of course there's no
objection from the landscape consultant
that it is suitable and appropriate for
its purpose which is to effectively mask
the developments from views
of the uh from and to the uh
uh registered park and garden and the
chilton hall collection of assets
clearly the the parish council uh and
lady hearts advisors are saying another
thing um it's for members to determine
effectively whether they feel the
strategy is sufficient or not or whether
something else is required and if it is
um then of course that's something to to
to come to uh fruition during the debate
thank you all for that okay uh
do you want to come back on that point
okay
well i mean the problem that we have is
we've got two sets of experts giving us
two sets of figures and uh
information
i don't think we're qualified to be able
to say that that set of experts figures
is right and another set of experts
figures is wrong in which case
bear in mind it's a heritage assets
we would probably have to err on the
side of caution and go with
the
the expert that
presents
the biggest buffer
because
if we go with the other one
we might be wrong
which is why i've suggested that we
should have a review
and do something about it if it's wrong
otherwise
i can't personally i can't see any other
thing to do than to say well yes we must
insist on a bigger buffet or smaller
houses
you say effectively members you you've
got to exercise your planning judgment
here you have got
two sets of opinions in fact there's
been a in their own ways the heritage
opinions provided have been subtly
different in in different ways and in
terms of the recommendations that
they've made
you know this isn't the case that you
simply weigh one against the other you
could even reach an alternative view
entirely based on what you've got before
you but the key is that you are
exercising your judgment i'm not sure
how at a later date you could say
we didn't quite get that right can you
have another go because depending on
what it is you feel that you'd assess at
that stage it might have wider impacts
upon the development i would i would
urge you to look at what you've got
before you today and decide whether that
strategy is going to be appropriate
you've heard from from mr pearce and the
the applicants the approach to the
strategy taken that there is a mix of
those heavy standard you know
established trees going in first and
foremost which will have that kind of
top uh canopy there is the thickening of
the existing hedge and there is the
lower canopy work as well to effectively
in in the applicant's mind and give that
impermeable screen
that was sought at the outline stage
[Music]
there was a requirement that the
landscape strategy is in general
accordance with what was presented at
outline as a matter of judgment officers
feel that that is the case entirely
thank you councillor parker followed by
cancer i was born
yeah thank you chip um
so i was going to ask a question but
actually it's largely been answered um
with the you know with the conversation
we've just had there actually but
um i'll still make the point chair that
it seems to me uh that the you know
we're not a million miles away from a
solution here uh all parties um
you know it's an excellent uh
application that's come forward uh and
the parish council have stated um that
you know they are uh you know they're
not opposed to this uh on on every
measure so
to all accounts what we're talking about
here is a compromise
so the question is really is
is is a compromise even an option to us
as a committee here today
um if it's not an option then that will
inform the debate it seems to me because
if it's not an option then we quickly
need to start talking about uh the whys
and wherefores um and our interpretation
of the harm on the side if if if
compromise is an option that would seem
to be the um
you know that the sensible route to take
so i'm just wondering if councillor
maybe suggestion of condition um is is
that possible or not we can only take
the uh the the views of our officers on
that so just need a bit of guidance on
this i think
yes i think compromise um
is what you're asked and i'll get the
officers to comment on that but i think
i have to remind you as i do often at
this committee we have to deal with
what's in front of us but i'll see
whether there is um
in terms of
see first and foremost we've got to make
sure that whatever is required is
necessary to make the development
acceptable it's not just a case of
saying oh let's have a little bit more
please it's got to be the case that is
what you've got before you on behalf of
the applicant acceptable or not is it
necessary to seek more as i say their
their strategy and they feel very
strongly that it is appropriate for its
circumstances i think the only other
thing to add is of course not only did
they take the outline permission um
seek to provide a strategy that was
informed by as in general accordance
with the original landscape strategy
they have actually sought to change the
parameters planned by amendments um to
push the built form further back and to
increase that plant and buffer so in
effect they have already done that and
they have reassessed the
the amount of
established trees that would be put in
um
so officers again i think would resort
to commending the recommendation to you
i think
that if what you perhaps are seeking is
another go at the mix itself rather than
anything else
then that perhaps could be done by way
of condition because it is directly
related to the reserve matters it might
be that you you ask for notwithstanding
the submitted details a resubmitted
planting plan
formed
you know on the basis of
whatever it is you feel is necessary
more trees slightly different planting
approach but as i say i mean we you you
need to be absolutely sure that's
necessary
vincent did you want to come in
running through my mind and i i'm
thinking about what uh
councillors busby and
parker and stephen have
said it seems to me
that at the heart of this
is the question of the density of
planting of the whips the under story
and i think as stephen has suggested if
we have a condition that requires
perhaps an increased density of whip
planting it does involve additional cost
to the applicant
but an additional
density of planting
then encourages whips to grow or thrive
they're competing against each other and
very often you find that they are then
thinned out
so if it's a question of
the
thickness of that screen it is a
question of density how many whips per
square meter are you planting
my feeling is that
that could be dealt with by
condition and the answer is you're
looking for an increase in that density
i understand i think i understand a lot
i'm just thinking that we need to be
clear who the decision maker will be as
to whether that's necessary which has to
be the local planning authority
and obviously the condition needs to be
so worded that it's lawful in every
respect i.e
it's enforceable
and and as steven says it's necessary
and it's in line in it is in line with
the outline permission
thank you um i've got councillor osborne
next
yes thank you mr chairman first of all
i'd like to express uh my thanks to uh
vincent for the
the presentation i thought it was
excellent and as uh councillor arthur
has already stated it's probably one of
the best i've heard since i've sat on on
planning
i
would like to um
i am in agreement with with with the
development i think it looks an
excellent development however i haven't
i have the concerns of the chilton
parish council and and lady hart the
objector
and that as you just said vincent
i think we ought to be looking at a
thicker a thicker amount of
growth from that area of screening but
also
to to go what the parish council want
and in fact have a have a larger buffer
area if that is possible so mediation
between uh the applicant and and parish
council would be excellent but
then again thank you thank you officers
for for an excellent presentation thank
you thank you i've got councillor davis
next uh but i think in answer to that i
think a condition could be
drawn up if we if we wanted to pursue
that any further we can come back to
that councillor davis
yeah
i'm glad to hear that last bit about the
extra condition
i'm just firming up the the buffer
i live in an area where i've seen this
happen in real life
where um
literally there was nothing on the
ground and trees
a mix of trees were planted and within
10 years it was a completely different
landscape and the screening was
was absolutely incredible i thought
among um
vincent's
uh
presentation he outlined very much the
the the effect if you like the broccoli
and then the different types of trees
how they would work in conjunction and i
i think that would work absolutely
perfectly if it's felt then that we
needed a little bit extra i think would
correct me if i'm wrong would that go
into the first point of the
recommendation where it says approved
plans and details secured
would that mix in with that
or would it have to be a separate
condition
um
but either way
i would like to propose we reckon we
accept the officer's recommendation uh
to grant approval
and seek a segment uh what with with
this extra beefing up of the
um
if that's what uh
the planning the corporate manager
believes is necessary then yes well uh
they're proposing what's in front of you
about that that's if you want to put a
condition honored
i'm asking if that would go in with the
approved plans and details are cured
right so i'll get i'll get a view on
that for you but i'll i'll come back to
you because your main proposal to accept
the officer's recommendation otherwise
thank you can you answer that um it
would need to be a separate condition i
think members have got before them
actually in the table papers
a schedule of proposed conditions were
they minded to accept a recommendation
i think it would be a case of adding a
condition
uh in terms similar to for example
condition four which relates to the
timetable and phasing of the approved
planting
i am thinking it would be along the
lines of not with so
no development apart from the access and
enabling workshop commence
until a revised soft landscaping scheme
specifying planting mix
of all trees to be planted within the
strategic landscape buffer at the front
of the site has been submitted to an
agreed in writing by the local planning
authority
that scheme shall include information to
demonstrate how it has been formed by a
programme for consultation and
engagement with the chilton parish
council planting should that be carried
out in strict accordance with the
approved details
um well
whilst you're reading that out i looked
up and the
applicant was nodding his head in
agreement what you were reading out so
i'm taken from that that it is workable
and obviously you can have those
discussions with them afterwards but i
think that the feeling is that cancer
davis is proposing the officer's
recommendation with that additional
points that you've made out to beef it
up and the nods from over there are
coming forward
[Applause]
um could i
uh sorry councillor mayberry could i
just address this to both lady hart and
the applicant
um you've heard all what's been going on
um
would you like to come forward and both
give a comment on that if you're both in
agreement then i'll accept both of you
to come forward if you're not then i
can't
i i think that's a wonderful suggestion
lady can i also hang on hang up
just just purely to clarify that this is
the is this the planting specification
as a whole or is it just in relation to
that under canopy mix
the under
canopy okay
would you like to join their
conversation um i'm happy to if it
involves the draft would you would you
like the officer to join you and the
applicant only just the two of you no
one else
um i'm sorry we're in debate and i've
been advised i can't allow that
conversation and counselor maybe please
don't take up a conversation with them i
don't think you can do that yeah i think
you oh well i i think it may be safer
all round that's all i'm suggesting
right so council may reason
unless as long as she's counseled maybe
he's not gonna say he's happy she's not
gonna say anything else
issues no you're not voting but you're
not going to say anything else to us
right that's fine no
but we'll have a five minute adjournment
membership
members uh we're now back in session um
thank you for all getting together and
uh perhaps trying to sort
this out but i have to remind members
that we are the duly elected members who
are responsible for the decision making
here this morning okay
um right can you uh take us on from
where we left off
right um i think i have what the party's
obviously been in discussion um there is
a condition that um
sorry no i'm just saying i'll come to um
councillor dave as uh after you've heard
what's said and you'll accept all that
or not yes um so there is a an agreed
form of words um that i will read now
and and
again quite unorthodox but if i get it
wrong then somebody needs to jump up and
down um
just put their hand up or put the sorry
yes put their hand over let's be
notwithstanding the submitted drawings
no developments apart from the access
and enabling works shall commence until
a detailed planting specification
and method statements
for all
trees
and soft landscaping within the
strategic landscaping buffer
brackets including consideration
of a grid matrix
system has been submitted to and
approved in writing by the local
planning authority
the details shall include information to
demonstrate how they have been informed
by a program of consultation and
engagement with the chilton parish
council
the approved data the development should
then be carried out in strict accordance
with the approved details
what i would then like to add members is
that the there should be in addition to
the resolution
that in the event that there is no
agreement between the parties
that when that condition comes to be
discharged it returns to the planning
committee so that ultimately if there is
a disagreement members will then need to
exercise judgment in terms of which
strategy is considered to be most
appropriate
well we i'm sure members would all be
happy with that last part right i will
now ask the two uh prospective parties
and just in in fairness um just as a
point of clarification i think it would
be wise i think also before we have a
firm proposal it'd be helpful to
understand that members are satisfied
with the scale of dwellings that has
been presented within the submission
thank you
right members i think on the scale
that's been put in
that was what was agreed um outline
you're happy with that or not
they're all nodding right now you've
heard all what's been said and cancer
davis are you happy to include all that
with the last provision if i can get
um the parish council which is lady hart
and the applicant which i've forgotten
your name because somewhere
uh timothy chivas um could you just
please
not or say yes that you agree to what's
been said suggested that's right
thank you lady hat
on the scale
let's go well i've just sought
clarification yes the members have said
that they're satisfied they hard to do
that right councillor davis would you
like to make your proposal again
yeah i think yeah well done to to both
parties there on agreeing that i think
this is eminently sensible so i'd like
to make the proposal that we accept the
officer's recommendation with the new um
condition as outlined by stephen
and that subject
absolutely yeah and return them to this
committee if it all breaks down there's
a disagreement yeah
right you're all clear on that members
oh then they haven't come into that
you're all clear right um counselor
barrett
i'd like to second that proposal please
thank you
um then members if you're now clear it's
been proposed by cancer davis seconded
by councillor barrett
they will accept the officer's
recommendation plus the additional
condition plus in the event of all going
wrong it will come back to the
planning committee all those in favor
please show
that's unanimous
thank you very much
thank you very much to both
the parish council and to the applicant
members um it's up to you we've got um
two more plans three more plans to do
do you want to have a break until
quarter past which means you would get
chance to get lunch or do you want to
carry on
oh
dave
we're already voted uh kenzler osborne
we'll carry on yeah yeah carry on and
can i just have your permission i've got
another meeting at one o'clock so you
don't need my permission
well no i'm just saying i'll have to
leave it right after this next
application right okay thank you we'll
carry our members that's the view of it
so all those that wanted to have a quick
break i'm sorry
thank you for members of the public for
bearing with us this morning uh
hopefully the rest won't be as
complicated as that one
let's move now
to 6 b
11 and prairie
water street
that's on page 17
and at samantha over to you
thank you chair
uh your attention is drawn to uh the
late papers where there's been a
revision of some heritage comments uh
following some further information from
uh the planning agent
uh the stance of the heritage team have
not changed
throughout the application even after
these further comments
the application is for the erection of a
detached dwelling and garage within the
grounds of lebanon priory a grade one
listed building within the lebanon
conservation area
the application comes to committee as it
is considered to be contentious
their objections from uh the lebanon
society suffolk preservation trust 15
residents the parish council historic
england and the council's heritage team
there have also been 37 letters of
support for the scheme
the application site is in the rear
garden of the priory to the south of the
dwellings in water street
water street is here
lebanon priory here
and the application site
is here
the access
drive is shown
the garden and flabnam priory is an
irregular shape which backs onto
numerous properties within water street
this plan shows the historic core of
lebanon with water street with many
listed properties that are colored here
this is the high street and then church
street runs up here with the church
and there's also bears lane
which is here
the site is contained within the
historic core of lebanon and is
associated with lebanon priory which
with open fields to the south the site
is within the conservation area with
many listed buildings running along
water street including the grade one
listed properties of lebanon priory and
de vere house
the built up area boundary
is marked here
and the site is clearly outside of the
settlement boundary
a public footpath runs along
south of the site
here and is accessed from bears lane
there is an application
that was granted by committee uh in
bayes lane of 25 dwellings in this
section here
[Applause]
this aerial photograph shows the context
of the site to the village and the wider
landscape
the site is outside of the built-up area
boundary but is considered to be well
located to access facilities within the
village because of its close proximity
to the high street
this plan shows the proposed layout of
the site the access is from water street
just here
and it would go through the car parking
area for a
priory farm court
and then over the grounds of lebanon
priory to where the house would be sited
in the southeastern corner of the site
the proposed eco dwelling would be
single-story and partially underground
with a green roof
to help minimize the visual impact on
its surroundings
two applications for similar dwellings
have been refused on the site previously
in 2009 and 2010
the 2010 refusal was then taken to
appeal and dismissed on heritage grounds
the application is a resubmission of an
application that was withdrawn earlier
this year
on
highway
sorry on heritage grounds
as the applicant thought that they could
address the issues raised by the
heritage team
uh this is the floor plan uh showing the
very contemporary design of the dwelling
there's a detached garage here
and the access drive would come in here
with parking area there's a large glaze
screen
just here to help with solar gain
this plan shows
the wider context of the layout of the
site
uh this is the bears lane development
with the application site that we're
looking at today
just to the
just off the slide actually up here
the parish council have objected to the
scheme because of the proposal's impact
on the green fringe of the village
and the relationship of the priory to
its link to the countryside
this area of lebanon has been defined as
a highlands landscape sensitivity in the
lebanon
landscape character assessment which
forms part of the adopted labyrinth
neighborhood plan
therefore development of this site is
contrary to the neighborhood plan
as you can see the bears lane
development leaves a wide swathe of land
between the village and the development
to allow for long views into and out of
the village across the rolling landscape
this is an important feature within the
neighborhood plan
the planning agent has helpfully
provided some cgis to help you visualize
how the dwelling may look
if it were to be constructed
uh this slide shows uh
shows the site looking from the south
with the footpath along the boundary
here
the dwelling is just popped in here
this shows uh the green roof of the
building and how
it's
quite buried underneath the ground
this is taken actually from the grounds
of the priory
again another view from within the
gardens
this shows the gouge in the landscape
that would be required to hide the
driveway
we're on to the photographs now this
shows lebanon priory from the street
from water street
[Applause]
this shows the access point with water
street from priory farm court
these are some of the buildings within
priory farm court and the parking area
this shows the application site the part
that's unknown is where the dwelling
would be located
and just some more photographs around
the site to give you some context of
how large the garden is and the
screening
but you will note that this was when the
the leaves were on the trees so during
winter it would look quite different
again this is showing the location of
the house
the garden is large and well screened
with trees there is very limited visual
into visibility between the site and the
buildings on water street however less
lesson substantial harm has been
identified by both historic england and
the heritage team because of the impact
the development would have on the
setting of the conservation area
the rear gardens of the property and
water street form an undeveloped space
between the historic core of the village
and the open countryside
when less than substantial harm is
identified the harm should be weighed
against the public benefit
in this case the public benefit is
limited to employment opportunities
during the construction phase and also
the addition of one dwelling to the
housing stock in lebanon
these limited benefits do not outweigh
the harm to the heritage assets the
scheme is also contrary to the aims of
the mppf local plan policies and the
labyrinth neighborhood plan and is
therefore recommended for refusal
thank you
um
councillor busby
i think you're probably going to be
aware of what i'm going to say
um
i think this is a very difficult uh
application to judge from photographs
because there are slopes on there that
you can't see
as you say the photographs are taken in
the summer i propose that we should have
a site visit on this one um to get a
full view of the impact because
i don't think those photographs give you
any
uh enough information anyway
thank you um
other members i can take that if um
you get a second a councillor osborne
yes sir thank you mr chairman you agree
canceled busby uh
quite correct in that it is very
difficult to look at a thing which was
done during the summer months
kenzler plum
on this point only
thank you chair i disagree it's so
obvious that this one needs to just be
refused because it doesn't meet the
labour neighbourhood plan of lavender we
need to support the neighborhood plans
and we need to show that very strongly
and straight away
thank you uh kenzala parker
well i i would disagree but for entirely
different reasons i think we're too too
far in advance of the debate to decide
whether we're going to refuse that or
not chair but um
yeah but i i i think you know there's
quite a lot of information within the
offices report i think the uh the the
photographs more than um
well more than necessary in this example
so um i wouldn't support a uh a request
for through a site visit on this
occasion
thank you
um
i've started and ended um any other
comments on this no um rob wanted to
come in
yeah i just wanted wanted to point out
to memphis because if if at this point
obviously we can take proposals at any
point through the meeting or when we're
on an application but in the interest of
hearing all the information that is
available to members
if we do go through any proposals i
from a good governance perspective as we
have members of the public that have
waited
quite a significant amount of time today
that we would hear all the information
then members could still choose to go
with that option
afterwards if so if they so choose
would you be happy to hear we have three
well we have um i'm never going to
pronounce your name but uh we have a
supporter the applicant
and we have councillor maybe so
um that means we'd have to listen to all
those three which could take 10 minutes
and um you could then put your request
for site inspection immediately
afterwards would you be happy with that
well
in a way yes but in a way no
sorry
speaking isn't going to resolve the
issue here the key issue is about views
it's the views from this position
through the back gardens it's a view
from somewhere else you cannot get a
feeling of whether that view is good or
bad by talking about it you've got to
see and you can't get it from
photographs because there
could be anywhere it could have been my
back garden i wish okay um i'm going to
make a ruler on this i hear what the
officer says and i
um accept that but i think in the
interest that we
proceed here i'm prepared to put for
allow you to put forward your request
now so you um wish the site inspection
for the reasons you've stated it's
seconded by councillor osborne all those
in favor of a site inspection please
show
one two three four five six six those
against
one one two three four four
that is carried we'll have a site
inspection i'm very sorry to the members
of public and the applicant that are
present um but this will not be
discussed now uh we will have a site
inspection which you'll be informed
about
and
it will get back to our
the earliest
planning committee meeting that we can
get it to
and the officers will inform you of that
thank you very much
members will now move on to
duke street hindustan on page 79.
[Applause]
[Music]
samantha over to you
okay
this application cover sorry this
presentation covers two applications
where the sites are adjacent and are
linked by a financial viability
assessment
the two sites are in duke street
hindusham the proposals are for the
erection of three dwellings and another
for 14 dwellings
i will start with a very brief history
of the two sites
in 2015 outline permission was granted
for the erection of eight dwellings
on this piece of land marked in red
in 2017 reserve matters were granted the
site included two affordable dwellings
which were protected by a section 106
agreement
also included in the southern part of
the site was an area of open space the
size of the development did not require
an open space contribution and therefore
was not protected by a section 106
agreement
this is the affordable dwellings and
this is the open space here
[Applause]
later in 2017
the site to the south came forward for
11 dwellings which included three
affordable and was approved
this plan shows the two development
sites
with the open space in the middle there
and a farm access
through to the field behind
the eight dwellings have now been built
and many are being occupied
uh these are the affordable dwellings to
the south of the site with the open
space area to just to the right of those
dwellings
this application is dc 1902585
which is item 6d and can be found on
page 95 of your agendas
three dwellings are proposed on the open
space area they would be a terrace of
three they are smaller dwellings to
those to the north which gives a better
mix over the whole two sites
the design and materials are similar to
those of the development that have been
built
each of the dwellings would have three
bedrooms the center dwelling is over
three floors because it's slightly
narrower in floor area
[Applause]
the site would be accessed using the
existing access point for the eight
dwellings
these are again the affordable dwellings
uh to the scheme of eight that have been
built out
and the application site is just to the
right
and this is the site that was previously
deemed as a open space where the three
dwellings are proposed
these are some of the dwellings opposite
the site
just to give you some context of
what the housing stock is like
the second application is for 14
dwellings and is item 6c on page 79 of
your agenda
the site has a live planning permission
for 11 dwellings which includes three
affordable dwellings
this current application
was accompanied by a financial viability
assessment which concluded that the live
permission is not financially viable
14 dwellings would be viable without
affordable dwellings
we sent the assessment to the district
valuer who concluded that two
affordables would still make the scheme
viable
this was accepted by the applicant
the application for the three dwellings
on the open space was received after the
viability had been carried out
the developer is the same applicant
for the sites
therefore we insisted that the viability
should include both sites
and
and the three dwellings was added to the
14 making a total of 17.
this has resulted in a total of three
affordable units over the two sites
being required and it is
financially viable which the applicant
has actually accepted
there are no particular constraints to
the site and the principle of
development has been established on the
site by the granting of the 11 dwellings
in 2017
this is an aerial view of duke street
and the current development gap this
does not show the eight dwellings that
have already been built
in the top section here
this is the proposed layout with the
affordable units to the south
there are two access points proposed
one on duke street here and the second
access point is of the farm access
this is the design of the two affordable
dwellings at the southern section of the
site
plots three and four just to give you an
idea of how the buildings have been
designed
uh plot five uh is the other affordable
unit which would be a shared ownership
and would have three bedrooms
the other two affordables at the
southern end of the site
of affordable rent and our two-bedroom
properties
this is just a selection of the other
house types that are proposed on the
site
uh plot 14
to the north of the site is the largest
dwelling and has five bedrooms
this is the street scene the mix of
housing includes market housing of one
five bedroom
three four bedrooms
five three bedroom dwellings and two
two-bedroom dwellings the affordable
element are two two-bedroom affordable
rent and one three-bedroom shared
ownership
this shows the internal road and the
dwellings
the designer materials will match uh the
eight that have already been built
giving a consistent character along the
eastern side of duke street
this shows the farm access
track to the fields behind and it's also
where one of the access points would be
for the 14 dwellings the open space
where the three dwellings are proposed
is on the left-hand side behind that
hoarding
[Applause]
this is looking south
from the farm track looking down towards
red house cottages
and this is looking back the other way
from the cottages
north towards the eight dwellings that
have already been built
these are red house cottages to the
south of the site
their simple design is reflected in the
affordable dwellings that sits behind
them
there's just a couple of photographs of
some of the dwellings that are opposite
site
neighbours have raised concerns over the
parking of vehicles during this
construction phase
on duke street
this was a problem with the previous
development it is my understanding i've
been told by the architect this week
that a compound has been secured to the
rear of the site on agricultural land on
which vehicles will be parked this can
be
this arrangement can be secured as part
of a condition with a can within a
construction management plan
although the proposal is not policy
compliant and does not provide 35
affordable housing the scheme has
received independent scrutiny and has
concluded that the site for 14 should
provide two affordable units
if the site for three is also added then
a third affordable unit unit would still
make
the development viable
the site for three would result in the
loss of an open space
but would provide an additional
affordable dwelling so there is a
balance to be made of which would be the
more important public benefit
most
applications are recommended for
approval subject to section 106
agreement to secure affordable housing
and rams contribution
conditions are set out at the end of
each of the reports
it has been suggested that you that you
discuss
the development for three dwellings
firstly
thank you
yes members
you've heard the officer's presentation
we'll take
the second part of the application which
is on page 95 because we have members of
the public here the same people for both
both
parts of this
and we have the parish council mr
les cole
if you say i'd like to come forward you
have three minutes to address the
committee
and you will have another three minutes
on the other one unless you just ditto
it's entirely up to you
good morning um so you want me to do the
14 first is that correct
the very first site
if get the right revision
right okay um i was going to say good
morning good afternoon i'm going i'm
representing hindustan chatterjean
parish council who rejected this
proposal for the following reasons
the parish council has objected to all
of the applications on this site
initially for the the eight new houses
and now for the additional three houses
the principle being lack of any proven
need the first of the initial eight
houses has been occupied since april of
this year but five of the eight houses
remain either unsold or unoccupied which
includes the two affordable housing
given the first phase remains unsold
what justification is there a demand
exists
when the application for the 8 was
originally submitted to the planning
department it was presented to the
parish council in october 2015.
the scheme was proposed with the
inclusion of new village green on open
space to be utilized by existing
residents as well as the new inhabitants
the location would avoid children having
to navigate half a mile to the existing
village green which includes walking
along the busy a-1071
the position of this open space on the
southwest corner of the site would also
act as a visual buffer zone between the
new houses and the adjacent open
cultivated land which is now potentially
going to be additional housing
the application applicant has stated
what would have been the new village
open space is now classified as unwanted
land it was not considered on as
unwanted land when it was used as an
enticement for the application of the
original eight houses in the last 10
years the number of houses in duke
street which have either been built or
been granted planning consent exceeds 50
at no point has any provision being made
for the residents of duke street the
possibility of an open green space
albeit small was considered by many to
be a desirable asset
the local primary school is faulty
capacity and due to the site constraints
it's impossible to extend or increase
the school facility resulting in more
primary aged children traveling by cars
to schools outside the village
the public report back mentioned that
only one resident has raised objections
to this application on the original
application of the eight houses for
outline and for full there was nine
objections at outline and there was five
for the full application this has led to
the belief with the residents that their
comments have little effect on the
outcome
much emphasis has been made by the
applicant and by the planners about the
excellent links to the centre of the
village and the ease of access via the
footpath during the construction of the
eight houses contractors vehicles
constantly blocked this footpath i had
hoped to show some photographs
demonstrating this but unfortunately it
was not being proved possible we would
ask however the restrictions to prevent
reoccurrence of this situation be
included in any condition and should be
should the permission be granted
with the construction of the eight
houses on this site regrettably no
restrictions were opposed by baber on
working hours and as a consequence
residents were occasionally woken on
early on sunday mornings by vehicle
movements and noisy plant operation as
with the parking issues we would ask
that necessary restrictions to control
this also be included in any conditions
thank you
thank you very much
members have you any questions for the
parish council
councillor davis
closer to your mic please i just want to
pick up the point about the construction
management plan i don't know if this is
right for the parish council or for the
officers to answer that
to ask the parish council um
where their concern is but i think it's
a question for our officers in due
course
so i'll start them
by asking you what your concern is about
this any future construction management
plan and previous ones
on the eight which have been constructed
there was absolutely no restrictions at
all on that site regarding working hours
parking on-road parking off-road parking
as a consequence we ended up with
vehicles completely blocking payments um
which resulted in confrontation she
would say between the residents of the
existing residents and the contractors
the contractors have not engaged at any
time with the parish council or with the
residents despite what we just heard
with the previous application for
sudbury we never had any engagement at
all
so it was contemptuous almost thank you
for that um could i just ask do you have
any yellow yellow lines in in the
village
in henry schumer's has now had yellow
lines
um applied in
george street by the the pub but there's
none at all in in
in
you are aware the parish council can
apply for yellow lines to be
to the county council
yes but the yellow lines in george
street which have been applied there's
no enforcement of them and so
that's another story yeah thank you very
much
help out on this
um it is normal practice to put a
standard condition on for uh working
hours uh during the construction phase
quite happy to put that on any
permission that's granted
also a construction management plan
would also deal with the parking issues
and it
it would ensure
that
what has been promised to me verbally
about a compound to the rear of the site
on agricultural land
would also be provided
thank you
we have philip williams
if you said i'd like to come forward you
also have three minutes in which to
address the committee
good afternoon
um i'm the i'm the developer of the
previous site and the further following
two sites
can you get closer to the market right
all right now yeah
so better that's better
um
out of all the 60 or so homes on duke
street there was only one objection who
asserts that there was a genuine need
for public open space on duke street
i'm building homes with large regards
set well back from the main road
allowing children to play safely in the
frontal rear gardens
there was no public open space on dew
street so was there a genuine need for
it i suspect not
the houses i build have large gardens
and so i'm not adding to that
requirement so if there wasn't a need
before and i haven't created a need
there is still no need
the previous owner offered voluntarily a
public open space it was not a condition
or a legal obligation and neither did
its inclusion weigh heavily on the
planning decision
the area is not big enough to be used as
a recreational area
you couldn't play football or throw a
frisbee
bayburg's communities department has
said about the 14 home application that
although warranting an open space
provision 10 plus dwellings its size
shape and location do not warrant
on-site provision it should be noted
that there is a recreational ground and
village hall within the village
so if the 14 application doesn't want an
open space this adjacent site with eight
certainly doesn't either as a hinterland
village hiltersham is well provided for
having a purpose-built football pitch a
mugger a play area adjacent to the
village hall or within a few minutes
walk
residents have raised the issues of dog
fouling in the area this unmaintained
open space would be ideal
for unsocial dog owners or even fly
tippers
so if children aren't going to be able
to use it who will the elderly
well why would they leave the comfort of
their own gardens to stand in a patch of
land adjacent to the road
there is also concern about the loss of
a buffer zone between this piece of land
and the 14 home site is a 36 foot wide
farm field access the full depth of the
sites which will be the new buffer zone
i'm offering three smaller three-bedroom
houses with a lower sales value
giving more people the opportunity to
buy one
the houses are set well back behind an
existing hedge which will be retained
and strengthened
the district valuer has concluded that
two affordable houses on the 14
and three if the two sites are approved
together
if the three are not approved now it
could lead to a non-related application
sometime in the future with no
affordable housing
there are already two affordable houses
on the adjacent development range which
i've just successfully sold to baber
in summary this is a good opportunity to
provide three private affordable
three-bedroom houses
there was never a need for a public open
space and there still is no need a
proper maintained recreational area is
only minutes walk away
an open space here shows no public
purpose other than for dog fouling and
rubbish accumulation
the buffer zone is maintained
baber get an additional affordable house
and there is no planning condition or
legal requirement for this open space
um i've got time i'm also happy to
answer the questions thank you very much
on the unsold houses the time was up uh
right members uh do you have any
questions
to put to the applicant
uh councillor busby you said that the
three beds three floor uh houses the
smaller ones
are going to be affordable market
affordable what kind of prices would
they be sold at
well just jstone based on the current
square foot we're getting for the uh the
other houses are sold there they should
market at about 260 000
in round pounds whereas the other houses
are built start from about 425
so they are
okay um any other questions
uh
plum
thank you can you tell me have you had
any discussions with the local parish
council
hello no no i haven't and there's a
reason for that if you'd like to you'd
like to know yeah i have um i generally
i come from a large contractor
background where um a heavy public
involvement with the
residents was generally encouraged
what i found there was you just you'd
give people plans of what's going to
happen next week this is what we're
doing that's what we're doing
plans necessarily change
then you then everybody gets upset
because their plans
what they thought was going to happen
isn't going to happen so you send out
another letter
trying to correct it all and that still
doesn't happen
what i tried to do was keep myself to
myself
the first thing i did was we built an
access into the site get ourselves away
from the public put hoarding up to keep
because if i
my site my building site will encourage
unfortunately thefts which we had if i
make my site secure it keeps everybody
around where i'm working secure
so it was a conscious decision not to um
have a of a consultation and i
understand the benefits of it but i
don't think it'd be appropriate at least
on this side i did receive one letter i
didn't get any none of the parish
council come up to me and said oh would
you like to give a presentation would
you like to do this would you like
people very welcoming people looking at
the site and talking to me about it
all i got was a very threatening letter
about
noise and nuisance and we went to
extensive lengths and enforcement
officers came out and said you're doing
nothing wrong mr williams crackle
thank you very much
any other questions uh councillor parker
hey miss williams have you conducted a
needs assessment um on this
no no no well the only needs i'm sort of
working on the basis is that houses are
selling well
i've got
two left
cancer parker
so the needs of the village in which you
are developing are on a consideration
for you
that's right
well what i have done is there's um
the most interest in sales is on the the
smaller smaller houses the twos and
three beds or the three beds on this
side but interestingly the most
expensive house sold first the largest
five bed hole house sold first and then
a large four bed but there's been a lot
of interest in the three beds so on the
next site so that's what hence i'm
building three
three bedrooms house on on this one at a
lower value to try and give more local
people more opportunity and on the next
site 10 out of the 14 are three bedrooms
or less
thank you
um all right who's next uh councillor
barrett
thank you um can you just tell us a
little bit because if i understand it
you are the developer who had the plot
of land that was going to be the open
space
is that right yeah so what were the
plans for that who was going to manage
that in the future if that had continued
uh it was um the previous the previous
owner offered this as a as an open space
and i bought the land from him with this
open space included
my understanding was that i would have
to maintain it for a year
or the council would then take it over
the council didn't want a silly piece of
land in the middle of the village to
maintain so in the end it would just
fall into complete it would just be an
empty wasted space and it would be a row
of houses a farm access next to a waste
ground true no one's going to maintain
it thank you thank you
uh i came to the jameson
uh yeah you have five properties left
and the eight you've already built
is that not the case
they all sold all right
eight houses on the site
um
three are sold and occupied the count i
sold two to the council successfully
last monday that i could get occupied on
monday i had a sale for through
unfortunately because my buyer's buyer
fell out
he couldn't make it work so he
he pulled out two weeks ago i have three
full asking price offers for that third
bed i have two four beds remaining
thank you
any other questions
no
thank you very much
thank you like just to return to your
seat for the moment um no we
know county councillor councillor busby
is the ward member but as he's also a
member of the planning committee he's
elected to remain a member of the
planning committee so he can take part
uh in in the debate
members it's now over to you and i'll
start with councillor busby
can i just clarify that yellow lines
wouldn't be a solution for construction
parking you wouldn't put yellow lines
down for that
there
it would take you too long to get the
yellow lines in place the buildings
would have been up and probably fallen
down by the time of the game taken but
yellow lines can be put in villages in
parish councils and and their county
council they're any schedules we haven't
been handling for a specific reason
which is to protect the school parking
outside the school
hitlersham have a
feel henchmen village feel they don't
have a need for any more houses and
generally that's probably true
they don't have facilities
apart from a very full school
a pub and a community hall there's no
shop anything like that
their policy of
backfill i.e they don't want
development behind
housing
extends throughout the village but as
you can see as a result of that for
those of you that know hindelsham it
means that you've got a very elongated
village starting with duke street and
george street and then to silver hill so
from one end of the village to the other
is
i don't mind and a half possibly
at least
the problem i find i have with the
police that policy of having them just
in ribbon development is that it means
that you block out all of the views
that have been there for for years and
this is
the first part of this of these two
applications will contribute to that
um before the eights and the three and
the fourteen that was an open field with
views from housing opposite it broke up
the houses that existed in in duke
street so there wasn't a continual line
of housing if we approve both of these
then that will go and
you will get a mile and a half of
continual housing without views in my my
opinion that is not what countryside
village should look like you should have
views across to the countryside so
that's my main concern
secondly
even at 260 000 that's that's not
particularly affordable it's
quite expensive
there isn't a need for the housing
within the village
um
and
i mean the picture that you saw of the
two little cottages
and they're the kind of things that i
consider to be affordable housing and
the kind of smaller houses that people
need and we're not getting those
these are huge grand houses you saw the
pictures of them they're not meeting our
needs
and that's why i guess the bigger ones
aren't selling so
of these three
i think if these weren't approved
that would provide at least a break
in those run of houses and give views to
the open countryside which should be a
typical village view and that's
why i don't really feel happy with these
three
thank you princeton busby i think all
i'd point out is that on the affordable
side
hinders him
looking at i would assume is an
expensive village so
affordable houses that could be
affordable there i don't know so i think
as members you should bear in mind that
affordable does represent where the
areas are um
anyway
uh
cancel a plum
are we asked allowed to ask the ward
member a question
he's not spoken
no he's not the board member
i'll ask a question why haven't you
asked for a site visit
because i wouldn't have wanted you to um
oppose it like you do all my requests
for site visits
thank you
i'm hoping that most people that travel
in we know come along that particular
area and would hopefully have taken the
opportunity to have a look at it yes but
i do uh cancel a busby
[Music]
never know to be mixed up with mr busby
before
no no
anyways um i've got well it's two things
really
i do have a an issue about the the
affordables and i thought affordables
were 80 of the market value so if these
houses are being valued at 260 surely
they should be on the market for 200 and
something
not and not at the full price so that
that was just a general question about
you know what affordable housing
actually means
and then the second question but
actually
it's about rams it's rams and not ramsar
yeah am i right
it's rams not ramsar
it's within the ramsar's site so
iran's contribution financial
contribution is required for each
dwelling
rams contributions are required in
certain area
where there's new new residential
development the the ramsar site is a
different notion where yeah
so sorry i didn't i didn't
um phrase the question very well it's
not so much a question it's an
observation because on page 91 and i
appreciate it's a different one uh it
says ramsar contribution and it's not
it's a rams contribution what i don't
want to happen is in the s106 agreement
it only go into a ramsar site instead of
the actual rams pot
it's definite in the section 106 it's
the rams financial contribution that is
stated
thanks to those from that council
any other
questions kenzler parker
yeah and um i apologize in advance if
this is a silly question but i do need
some clarification on this so um
well i'm not sure chair but
um this is outside of the built-up area
boundary yeah
and so to what extent then as the
decision-making body do we have to take
the
established prints well the fact that
there is already development in place to
what to what weight do we have to give
that
um in in in determining something that
else that comes forward that is outside
of the build our very boundary
council parker i can't really tell you
how much weight to give it but it's it
is a question of weight it is a material
consideration
um that it falls part of the site that's
already developed um that is something
to bear in mind but i think what strikes
me as being one of the
over
key issues here is that it's the extent
to which this element of the site
remains a really important feature for
the
contribution it makes to the character
and appearance of the area perhaps as a
kind of a break point between what
otherwise would be a a kind of a
continual grain of development and
whether members feel that it's important
to retain that breathing space or not is
of course for for them to judge
yourself
any other
questions
uh kenzler i was born yeah thank you mr
it's just a question really and and that
is dealing with the open space element
that that the
applicant was involved with
did
we public realm side have any input into
what was the area that was needed
and and the other question would be
would if there was an open space area it
wouldn't be public realm would look
after it in terms of ourselves would it
be a management uh construct
management
construction of of
those of those properties
uh the problem is that the
the open space was attached to the
development for eight dwellings
that site wasn't big enough to trigger
an open space contribution therefore it
wasn't protected by the section 106
agreement
it was offered up
for whatever reason to make it a more
attractive place
i don't know
however we don't really have power over
that
and as being as it's been explained
the district council do not want to take
on the responsibility for the management
of that piece of ground
thank you thank you any other cancer
busby
but it's true that if you take the eight
houses and the 14 making 22 then there
would be a requirement for some open
space
and
without
looking at
the parish rep i'm sure the parish
council would look more than happy to
look after maintain that particular site
well it is an assumption but i'm sorry
we should not
rule out having open spaces because we
can't find somebody to look after it
we've got to volunteer in terms of i'll
go and do it if need be
in the parish council if the parish
can't do it i'll do it elsewhere
we should have open spaces
finding somebody to look after it is a
different problem altogether and it
shouldn't be a decision
come into a decision
like this
any other questions
any other debate
right well in the view
that no one's coming forward i shall
move the officer's recommendation from
the chair of approval do i have a
secondary so we'll move on uh kenzler
parker do you wish to comment
yeah i will do chair you know just
briefly just to say that
it's very
you know it's very unfortunate this one
um
and increasingly we're seeing it aren't
we within the district so
um i i would just implore uh not for one
moment am i suggesting to the parish
that you know that development coming
forward is um you know is is in some way
you know their fault but i would implore
uh
uh parish councils and communities to
engage in a neighborhood planning
process because it it makes it very very
difficult for us to resist something
because um
you know other than the fact that uh
it's outside of the build up area
boundary etc i have to agree with the
officer's recommendation in here it's
very difficult for us to do anything
otherwise and i absolutely understand
the frustration that communities feel um
you know just be minded to say that
there are you know there are potential
remedies to that
thank you
any other i don't um
other comments oh
yeah just make a comment i i think it's
interesting that it's a plot that
it's obviously like a it's a bit like a
windfall plot for the developer as to
what to do with it
and um in some ways they could have come
forward with an application for a four
bedroom or five bedroom house
and um and actually they've put forward
something that is uh more affordable and
provides more opportunity for people so
yeah i'm gonna go with the the uh
officer of their recommendation
um
and that's one of my influences
uh
parker you wanted to come back uh well
i'll just come back to something that
was mentioned earlier i mean one thing
that we can most definitely do for our
communities and that is to condition the
working hours um uh if
could make that amendment pick that up
yeah
and the construction management plan
that is picked up okay
right it's been proposed and seconded
members there's nothing new to bring
forward
all those in favor of the officer's
recommendation please show
one two
three four five six seven eight
those against
two that is carried thank you
right we'll move on to page 79.
um
we've already had the application
described to us obviously if there's any
questions you need to ask the officer
will update you
we
i should now ask public speakers again
to come forward and
there's nothing more you want to add at
this stage
mr cole
parish council
we are now on the page you wanted post
79 to start with
okay
good afternoon thank you again um again
i'm representing hindustan chatterjean
parish council object to this proposal
for the following reasons the parish
council objected to all of the
applications for both this site and the
adjacent site which did say next on the
agenda but there you go the major
objection for this proposal is there's
no proven need for any additional
housing of this type and size the
addition addition
the adjacent scheme which has the first
house occupied in april of this year
still has five the eight houses
unsold or unoccupied despite what we've
just heard um the local primary school
is full to capacity and due to the
physical site constraints it's
impossible to extend the school or its
facilities
this will increase
this increase in house numbers is in
addition to two other developments for a
further 12 houses in duke street
these have already been granted with one
currently under construction completely
unrelated to these applications
additional houses will create the need
for more parents to drive their primary
school aged children to school further
away
there's no reference in the public
reports back to the comment from mr tony
bass which was mentioned by the
applicant uh previously although
warranting and open space provision 2010
plus dwellings its size and shape and
location do not want on site provision
um it makes no mention of the distance
the open space which is half a mile away
um and you have to walk along the busy
a1071
now baber are combining this application
with the application for three
offensive change
it makes sense that when evaluating the
leaf owned space the total of 17 houses
should have been used in the calculation
which is significantly higher than the
threshold of 10.
there's no reference or two or
amendments made to the proposed layout
in response to the series of
observations and recommendations
provided by suffolk and stapley this
highlighted several potential security
issues with the site layout
and the applicant's residential dwelling
unit template incorrectly lists 14
market value houses and makes no
reference to any affordable shared
properties if this application is
successful what safeguards will they be
given to ensure that the developer
complies and creates three affordable
houses
thank you
thank you for that you're well within
your time and members have you got any
questions
no
thank you very much
um i know call on mr phillip williams
right so you also have three minutes and
we're on page 79 okay
thank you
um
all the objections raised against this
application have been strongly rebutted
by the planning officer
this application is for three more
dwellings within the same parcel of land
the designs will follow the same
principles as the adjacent site
and weber building patrol has put that
site forward for or asked me to put it
forward for the labc east anglia
building excellence awards 2020.
this application will now have the same
spacing and density as the adjacent site
which is selling well
purchasers particularly like the open
space at the front of the site with the
houses being set well back from the road
and the large rear gardens with extended
open views
the only serious question to resolve was
how many affordable houses could the
site carry
i paid for an extensive viability study
and for the council's own district value
to assess our findings he came up with
an alternative view which we've agreed
with
out of the 14 houses 10 are two and
three beds and there are three four beds
and a fiver
so in summary the site already has
planning permission for eleven houses
this is for only three more on the same
piece of land
the houses are the same popular design
the same spacing and density and the
district value has decided how many
affordable houses should be included
i therefore see no reason why this
application shouldn't be approved
i i can also
i know there are the parish have
concerns about um working hours and
parking etc etc i'm very conscious of
that very conscious indeed
i hate working weekends i don't like
working my my blokes at the weekend
because it just it doesn't actually get
any further
occasionally stuff happens
things happen on site if you're in the
middle of a concrete pool and something
breaks down and you have to come back
the next day and do it you have to come
back and do it otherwise you're into
breaking up concrete
parking we did our very utmost to keep
everybody off the road as long as we
could i can't physically
be out there all the time telling them
to stop parking on the pavement i'm
conscious that people walk prams up and
down their pavement and i don't want i
have kids i have families i don't want
the pavement blocked by my blokes fans
i've got them off the road as soon as we
can as the site gets built out
there's limited places to put vans so
they're parked on the road occasionally
if somebody runs up the curb we will ask
them to get off
thank you thank you
members have you any questions
no thank you very much
right members um we'll go into debate
councillor busby would you like to start
thank you chad
it's interesting isn't it um
heritage
we've had a lot of discussion over
heritage this morning
and about how important it is to get a
view
now
these were from uh particular buildings
but there were views over heritage sites
here we're going to be blocking off a
view of
ancient plateau clearlands and ancient
estate clearlands
surely an ancient
view is as important
for a village as for a house
this is going to be blocking off
important
um
countryside it's an important view for
this village
you can't have it both ways we can't say
it's all right for
chilton hall to demand that they get a
view
but not can you come back
a bit on the painting i don't know
oh sorry
my mistake uh he's got an answer to that
on point one but anyway did you wish to
carry on before
oh
right
not an answer as such but just really to
point out to members of course
and we're not dealing with designated
heritage assets here ancient farm
clelands and plateaus they're landscape
character types it's just a way of
defining and understanding the landscape
which is of itself an important
consideration but it's not subject to
the same statutory duty that the
designated heritage heritage asset would
be i think it's just important that
members realize that what i would say
however is um just to make clear that
bearing in mind the decision that
members have just taken whilst planning
permission is yet to be granted on that
site i think the fact there is now a
resolution to grant
does uh impact on the decision you're
about to take so you do need to factor
in the fact that you have just approved
resolve to grant permission for those
three dwellings adjacent which might
then affect your your weighing up and
understanding of potential views upon
the character and appearance of the area
as opposed to heritage assets well
it makes it more important that we get
this decision right having made i
couldn't say the wrong decision but the
decision for the last one but in my view
a view is a view
you can't you can't wait and say oh well
that view is important because of a
house and this view isn't important
because it characterizes a village
it doesn't have to be a heritage asset
it's important to the people of the
village in that in my opinion that's
just as important as
chilton hall's view and the person that
lives there
thank you
uh cancel owen
this might be a silly question but what
houses are we actually going for here
because i'm looking and it's um
you've got you've got um
granted for
a direction of eight dwellings and
you've got
what page
then once so
so we because we're saying we're only
going for three more are we
on this one or are we going for the
whole
i'll get clarification for you yeah
there's um 11 dwellings
that have already got planning
permission that permission is live they
could start at any time once they've
discharged their conditions
uh
what the
financial viability assessment
came across was that that scheme was not
viable because it included three
affordable dwellings therefore they
wanted more dwellings to make it
financially viable
so it's changed from 11 dwellings to 14
dwellings
so it's three more
and i can i come back on that what three
what are they adding then as in from the
last lot so obviously are they adding
the one five bedroom or are they adding
a four bedroom a three bedroom to what
they went for the first time
do do so do you get what i'm getting at
we got the answer
[Music]
well yes i think so i mean sam was the
was the i don't know if she was the
original case officer but from what i i
gather from the papers if you look at
page 85
the extant permission and all the
permission has been referred to in the
past was for an outline scheme so the
final mix was probably unknown because
it would have been left to the reserve
matters to pick that up
but what you do have on page 85 is a
schedule there of the dwellings that are
proposed so you've got
one five bed three four bed five three
bed and two two bed they're all markets
and then in addition you've got the
three affordable dwellings um two of
which would be two bed for affordable
rent
and then one would be a three bed shared
ownership property
okay so i'm sorry was it is the case the
eleven houses is now it was an outline
and no reserve matters came forward
and we now have 14 on a full
application right thank you
any other comments members
uh cancer jefferson
i noticed that the suffolk county
council have said there's no available
or surplus places in the catchment area
schools for the schools so if we do
agree these
along with the three we've just agreed i
mean there is a potential for
families to turn up with nowhere to go
to school
um it is actually a sill application
that would have to be applied for for
the school places
there is some space in lincolnshire
apparently
though
they apply to the um seal and money's
taken towards the transport um
schools uh home to school transport
isn't it so they'd bust them somewhere
uh
any other community members
no uh councillor barrett
it's a
suggestion that we move towards
making a decision
we seem to have concluded our debate um
i'm suggesting that we uh now move to uh
approval so i'm recommending approval so
you're proposing it do i have a
secondary counselor parker do you want
to comment
only just to say uh again same as before
um
you know it's it's
we i think we would all like to support
our communities um i i think you know
it's not material but i think the
approach to development here is is
somewhat robust et cetera et cetera but
unfortunately our hands are tied by the
mvpf same as we've said before chair
well i'm sure the applicant has heard
that and we've noted that
they can and that does include the
condition for the work and hours
management just to double check that you
would want extra conditions for working
hours to restrict the working hours and
a construction management then
um it's quite standard isn't it so i
think that's
because we have noted what the applicant
has said about
you know that they tend not to want to
work at these unsociable times
right any other comments
no
it's been proposed and
it seems to me that if we approve this
then we just we're just saying that
we'll build houses anywhere that
developers want to do it whether there's
a requirement there or whether the
village or the parish want it
and if that's the case then i think
we're throwing ourselves open to all
kinds of applications there's no reason
to be
putting houses here there's no need the
parish don't want it it's just purely
for the developers profit that's all
davis
yeah i have a lot of sympathy with
councillor busby's
plea there although we know it's going
you know
the way this is going to go and i do
think that
we put we boxed ourselves into a bit of
a corner with the three beforehand and
now and now the uh the 11 we had before
so
it is ostensibly three more
but if it does mean proper affordable
homes in terms of the the the two rented
and the one shared ownership then that
does balance it to to an extent but i do
think as a planning committee we need to
be a lot more mindful of
you know what is needed in individual
villages although i know our policy
is it's district-wide so
i would just remind members that we do
have outlined plan permission here for
11.
okay
no new comments
right as brim proposed and seconded all
those in favor please show
one two
three four
five
and those against
one two three
four
that is carried out
yeah yeah
well members i think we got to the end
of the agenda
we've come back to the minutes which
i can now propose to you that we
accepted they are in order so i'll run
through them you stop me at any page
um if you got any queries because i want
to sign them as a true record
and that's the minutes of wednesday the
20th of november
page one
page two
page three
page four
[Music]
page value
page six
page seven
and page eight
can i have a proposal funding sign them
as a true record to cancel the busbee
seconded by kensal plum all those in
favor
that's carried thank you very much i'll
sign them
i do have a date at the next payton
[Applause]
[Music]
the next uh the next meeting is
scheduled for wednesday the 15th of
january
so we're going to let you off next
wednesday okay we thought that you might
like that and we'll also let you off the
first one in the new year
so
bearing in mind next year's 2020 does
that mean that we're all going to have
superb vision and get the decisions
right well we will try to improve all
the time cancer busby
i'll declare the meeting close thank you
very much
merry christmas to all of you
you